[Music]
thank you
sleep in sex so this is something we did
not talk about in our last conversation
where should we begin
with grabbing people and talking about
the interplay between sleep and sex
maybe we could start with how sleep
impacts sex and
begin with actually the literal idea of
separating those bed fellows and to the
question of should you have a sleep
divorce as a couple to prevent a real
one and sleep divorce is sleeping
separately that's right yeah so a sleep
divorce is where you will sleep either
in separate locations or at least in
separate beds the diluted version of the
Sleep divorce rather than sleeping in
separate rooms and separate beds is
called the Scandinavian method which you
think is sounds so much more salacious
than it actually is which is essentially
you've just got two separate beds that
you put side by side and that's the diet
version of a sleeve divorce but I do
think that sleep divorce idea is
important because it is a taboo and it
also canmarkedly improve things for
people
so when we've looked at survey data both
in the US and also in the UK with the
national the Sleep counselor what you
find is that about one out of every four
couples who are surveyed will tell you
that they have had a sleep divorce that
they will sleep in separate beds
and we think that that may be in part an
underestimate because of the stigma
associated with it and if you survey
people anonymously you get to a number
of almost one out of every three people
will admit to waking up at least in
different locations
and there is pretty good evidence from
the science as to why that number may
make sense you know why 25 of all
couples suggest that
when we study couples who are sleeping
together objectively on almost every
measure that we can quantify about sleep
sleep is worse when you're sleeping as a
couple relative to when you're sleeping
separately
the twist in the tail there though is
that when you ask people about the
satisfaction of sleep there is
definitely some group of individuals
that say look I feel more satisfied with
my sleep when I'm sleeping with my
partner than when I'm sleeping
separately despite the fact that
objectively their sleep is worse so I'm
not suggesting it's a a
one-size-fits-all
but I think the taboo comes from the
idea that well if you're not sleeping
together then you're not
sleeping together
and the exactly intercourse thank you
very much yeah can we just get over this
way it's my desperately unfortunate Hugh
Grant genes that has me sort of trying
to navigate around the topic rather than
just like saying it straight so thank
you Tim yes if you're not sleeping
together then you're not having sex
you're not having intercourse yes but
the oh come on Matthew hold it together
turns out that the opposite is true that
when you get a couple who are sleeping
well their sex life actually improves
and it's probably for three reasons that
we've uncovered the first is hormones
the second is
sensitivity and the third is libido and
I'll try to
Park my acute Grant and get right into
it in terms of the hormones take off the
gloves Matt check out the gloves come on
it's time I'm wondering what you what
you mean by saying take off the glove in
terms of this conversation but let me
just skip it you see you open the door
Tim and I walked right through here we
go or put on the gloves yeah I think
probably best but we know each other
quite well now so maybe anyway in terms
of the hormones firstly we know that
testosterone gosh it takes a pretty
sharp nosedive in males and in females
when you're not sleeping well males who
if we put them on a diet of maybe four
or five hours of sleep they drop their
levels of testosterone
somewhere by about 10 years of Aging so
a lack of sleep will age a man by a
decade in terms of virility it's also
true of estrogen in women and so when
those two sex hormones are not in play
you get a reduction in the quality of
the sex life the second component and
this is data that we've only really got
in females less so in males but the the
sensitivity of female genitalia
increases when sleep is in high volume
versus when people are not getting
sufficient sleep and we think that's due
to the estrogen that when estrogen is in
normative amounts because you're
sleeping well there is greater vaginal
lubrication which therefore leads to
Greater sensitivity and greater pleasure
by way of sex
and then the final aspect is libido
we've also found that when a woman
obtains an extra one hour of sleep
there is a 14 increase in her
desirability to be intimate to have sex
with her partner
and I find that interesting because if
you put it in context the FDA approved
drugs for increased libido in in women
things like I think it's called violisi
is one of them I know that will increase
libido in women by about 24 percent but
here is the simple addition of one hour
of extra sleep you can get more than 50
percent of that benefit drug free
question for you Matt how are these drug
companies measuring increases in libido
is it a self-reported one to ten scale
or something like that which can be very
fungible
it's self-reported so many of those
scales are subject you know it's very
much like pain that it's when it comes
to libido it's somewhat difficult to
quantify and of course it's not just
about in a biological libido the
conditions have to be right you have to
have the relationship with your partner
which actually also reminds me by the
way when couples are not sleeping well
this is a study from UC Berkeley not
from my lab but
what they found is that they have more
fights they don't resolve conflict
nearly as well between them when they're
having a fight and the reason is because
you lose empathy when you're not
sleeping well your ability to empathize
within other individuals and we now have
demonstrated why in terms of the brain
networks you decrease that capacity for
understanding the other and no wonder
you're fighting and you're fighting in a
pretty poor way so what's the Playbook
what's the best practices good question
I think
I'm not suggesting that asleep divorce
is for Everyone by any means whatsoever
there are some people for whom they
adore sleeping with their partner for
lots of reasons safety security intimacy
but I think if you are interested in it
take us graded approach and I would
suggest firstly just having an open
gentle conversation and don't be
defensive about it the second is
don't suggest that it's permanent offer
the idea that look could we do this you
know darling could we do this for the
next week or the next two weeks and I'm
not suggesting it's forever let's just
see and let's just try it on for size
then I think what people misunderstand
about
sleeping together in the same bed is
what they miss they don't really miss
the majority of time because for the
majority of time you're asleep and
you're non-conscious what you really
miss are the book ends of sleep that
sort of getting into bed having a cuddle
saying a good night and in the morning
waking up and doing the same thing so if
you have a sleep divorce what you can
also do is build that in so you know
whoever goes to bed first the other
person comes in you have your time you
sort of cuddle do whatever you need to
do and then you leave and then you
repeat the same process in the morning
you don't have to do that every day of
course it's not going to be practical
but in that way you sort of get the
benefits of sleeping together whilst
still having a sleep divorce if that
makes some sense so I would just say you
know be be honest with yourself
feel like sleep divorce needs a Rebrand
maybe Furniture polyamory since you'd be
on separate pieces of furniture sounds
really sort of risque taboo kind of sexy
I am so stealing that because yeah when
you bring that up you know in a dinner
conversation and you finally admit it to
your friends they all think oh no
they're on the Rocks you know but
Furniture polyamory all sorts of you
know swings from the ceiling and oh it
sounds very exciting very exciting yeah
candle works on the nipples let's go
they're killing it yeah yeah yeah
exactly honey we've got a we've got to
switch things up if they're doing that
yeah it's a question that is always
been unanswered for me I have some
theories but why is it and this is my
assumption just based on Broad Strokes
having had conversations with many
people about this and observed this also
online
seems that men tend to run hot and women
tend to run cooler in the sense that men
will often want the temperature in the
room to be lower the sheets or the
bedding to be thinner I mean this is
part of the reason why I use devices
like eight sleeps not the only thing out
there they do sponsor the podcast but I
use them before that so you can have
zones of temperature is that
and I don't know if
this is something you've looked into it
is that mostly attributable to muscle
mass and thermogenesis is it hormonal
how do you explain that if you have an
explanation muscle mass thermogenesis
it's also regarding and thermogenesis
really comes on to metabolic rate and
then it's also hormonal based on
testosterone which is in part of
thermogenic hormone in and of itself
that temperature difference we can
measure and we can see it actually
because studies were done before we were
looking at this not related to sleep but
just related to core body temperature
and they demonstrated that there are
some age dependencies to it though that
once you get past about 50 or 60 the
differences between men and women start
to collapse and they start to become
much more similar to each other than
they are different why is that it could
be in part because of the reduction in
testosterone that happens also because
of the muscle mass degradation that
occurs in males as well but that
evidence of males in general running hot
is well demonstrated and it does bleed
over into the night and cause those
often sleep problems that's some of the
reason that some people will get fussy
about sleeping together a lot of it is
about movement it's about also snoring
is a big concern
with Desiring a sleep divorce or it's a
motivating factor I should say so we've
talked about One Direction we've talked
about how
sleep effects sex what about the other
direction is sex helpful deleterious to
Sleep Quality what are the factors if
someone's trying to give themselves the
optimal dose of of sex to
improve sleep if there is such a thing
yeah and one should never state that
that's the reason you know you say
darling could be just Venture into the
bedroom of course well it's because I've
had really rough sleep the past couple
of nights and could you just like please
knock me out that's a crowd pleaser yeah
yeah isn't it just there's a real
divorce rather than a sleep one but I
think the evidence is actually favorable
that when we look at when we survey
couples what we find is that sleep
although there's a caveat here
sex as long as it's associated with
orgasm and I'm not pointing to any one
of the the two Sexes maybe males but
please keep keep this in mind that sex
as long as it accomplishes orgasm is
associated with about 70 percent
increase in reported Sleep Quality that
following night and people do fall
asleep faster as a consequence and we're
learning about the mechanisms but I
would say that it's probably quite
depressing to hear that news if you're
let's say you're single or you don't
have a partner or your partner is away
for a while you don't have to worry too
much
because it turns out that masturbation
is a reasonable stand-in and what we've
also discovered is that masturbation
again as long as it's associated with
orgasm produces a 47 increase in your
sleep quality
actually it will decrease the speed with
which you fall asleep by about 50 and
you'll hear this a lot some people will
say they use it as a method when they're
struggling with sleep they will actually
masturbate to try to to help their sleep
so so masturbation is not as impactful
as intercourse based on the data but
it's a sizable benefit that
you know the rest in your hands I guess
but it's it's a non-trivial benefit it's
a playful topic of course and and we
joke but I do find it interesting
regarding the biology and we've tried to
scratch the surface here and and dig
down firstly what we found is that the
benefit of sex with orgasm on sleep is
hormonally related but now it seems to
be that when
women
engaging intercourse that results in
orgasm there is an increase in a hormone
called oxytocin which I'm sure many
people have heard of now to a lesser
degree that there is also an increase in
men but firstly we know that oxytocin is
a sleep-inducing molecule and you can
inject this into the brains of different
animals we don't do animal work we do
human work but you can see that sleep
induction benefit the benefit in men
seems to actually be about a different
chemical called vasopressin and although
that story is just starting to emerge it
seems to be those two hormones oxytocin
more so for females vasopressin for
males so vasopressin that's interesting
to me because vasopressin is as I
understand an antidiuretic hormone
sometimes given to sort of adolescent
bedwetters also well when it's
prescribed as desmopressin I suppose
this is maybe a topic for another time
but seems to have an impact on
short-term memory which is quite
interesting
to me but
how does vasopressin help sleep
maybe it just keeps you asleep longer
because you're not inclined to get up
and go to the bathroom I don't know I
mean that's one of the reasons why
it's prescribed as Desmond present as
well it's possible but it seems to have
a sleep-inducing mechanism and we don't
truly understand why but we think that
it's perhaps working at two different
levels of the brain one is directly at
the level of the brain stem itself where
you're starting to shut down the Wake
promoting regions and I think we
discussed that in the the previous
episode things like
histamine or adrenaline serotonin so one
component is working at the level of the
the brain stem the second is working at
a much smaller structure but more in the
middle of the brain called the
hypothalamus which is actually where we
have What's called the sleep wake switch
and it's literally like a flip-flop
device and there is some signaling
direction of vasopressin on that sleep
switch within the hypothalamus itself
too but right now I think it's it's
pretty unclear as to exactly how those
mechanisms unfold but I do find them
interesting because if we're looking for
novel sleep aids
you know all joking aside then should we
be thinking about combinations of
oxytocin and vasopressin as novel sleep
inducing
capacity I think the second part of
those two
chemicals however is also the other side
of the coin which is the nervous system
itself that when you are engaged in the
act of sex you're the fight or flight
branch of the nervous system What's
called the sympathetic nervous system
which is not that at all it's very
agitating and aggravating
it actually should be called the three
F's Branch now I think about it which is
the fight the flight and the
and the fornication branch of the good
safe good safe of the nervous system
you're you're Grant honorary degrees
but what's interesting is that you
cannot fall asleep when your sympathetic
nervous system is switched on yeah and
I'm sure you've had the experience I've
had this too where you're you know that
you're tired you know that you are so
sleepy and fatigued but maybe it's
because you know you've just done a big
event on stage and you're just so wired
and it's called the wired but tired
phenomenon where yeah you're desperately
wanting sleep but you can't the reason
is because your sympathetic branch is
still switched on but post-coitly what
happens is that you go back to the
opposite side which is the
parasympathetic which is this quiescent
calming branch of the nervous system and
that is the Royal Road to better sleep
so it's almost as though the orgasm
removes the block of the flight or
flight branch of the nervous system and
pushes you into that relaxed autonomic
State and so I think that's you know how
do we work that with new sleep novel
medications sleep inducing novel
medications too
so a few things come to mind for me
number one is guys this doesn't mean you
have free license to open your extremely
bright blue light emitting laptop and
watch a bunch of porn right before bed
because that may
that may stem some of the benefits so
you're gonna have to use that
imagination instead of God knows what
arms race you're watching on PornHub
second is guys buy a Hitachi Magic Wand
get the wireless Edition you'll thank me
later if you are in a heteronormative
relationship that's for your lady friend
and she will thank you as well I'm so
wet behind the ears I'm now can we
please link to in the show notes so that
I at least can click on the thing I'm
just gonna edit that so you just say I'm
so wet and then I take out behind the
ears and see what people come back with
they'll be like wow that Matt Walker's
really he's really taken a side road we
didn't expect yeah yeah I I knew that
you know maybe he and Tim were friends
but I this I know I'm taking this stuff
yeah where's that position in Austin for
me at the University
quick to jump from UC Buckley anyway
sorry so let's talk about another
let's say Aid outside of the Hitachi
Magic Wand and speed wank before bed
which I know I'm violating the the road
map that you and I discussed a bit so
I'm hopping ahead a little bit but let's
talk about it because it's on the Mind
melatonin
how would you suggest people think about
if you look out there in terms of the
Silverback 500 pound gorilla of the
sleep supplement world it is melatonin
it commands a multi-billion dollar
segment of the market which is utterly
stunning to me
melatonin is not really going to be your
sleep friend and for a number of reasons
I think people
don't understand what melatonin does
melatonin is a hormone by the way it's
it's sometimes called the hormone of
Darkness or the vampire hormone just
because it comes out at night it doesn't
doesn't mean that you start like biting
into people's necks but it's simply that
it signals night time to the brain and
what that does is it regulates the
timing of your sleep but it doesn't
participate in the generation of sleep
itself
and so you could think of melatonin like
the starting official at 100 meter
Olympic race that melatonin brings all
of the races to the line and Begins the
race but it doesn't participate in the
race itself that's a whole different set
of chemicals
so melatonin is potentially useful when
you're traveling between different time
zones but once you're stable in a time
zone that evidence is very clear when we
look across all of the studies and we
gather them together in the same
statistical bucket and it's called a a
meta-analysis approach
what you find is that melatonin will
only increase the speed with which you
fall asleep by 3.9 minutes which is
really not that different to Placebo and
it only increases your sleep efficiency
by just 2.2 percent
which is really not fantastic as a sleep
aid
but it's understandable when you then go
back to what we were just describing as
the mechanism why would it improve the
quality of your sleep if it's there to
help the timing rather than the
generation of sleep itself does that
make some sense Tim yeah it does it does
and I think this is also a good place to
talk about not just the minimal upside
because I would say there are people out
there and I've experienced this when say
traveling internationally it it does if
you take a walloping dose it can help
put you down so I would imagine the
efficiency and the effect on reducing
onset time is dose dependent on some
level so you can brute force it and it I
have found it very helpful say going
from one side of the planet to the other
however and I will use it too in those
circumstances that's the only time I
typically but there are taxes that you
may pay and it makes me think about I
don't want to steal the mic here but a
conversation I had with someone actually
actually a very smart researcher
probably 10 years ago and he mentioned
in passing that he took eight milligrams
or 10 milligrams of melatonin every
night and I remember talking to him and
saying I'm no scientist but
my guess is that if you take something
that is produced in the body
or something that is very similar right
so you could have
say
a luteinizing hormone and HCG right very
comparable and if you start exogenously
meaning from the outside in
providing your body with X it is going
to have a negative feedback loop and
things are going to start to happen so
it doesn't strike me just again starting
from those principles the taking
melatonin
continuously eight milligrams a night
would over the long term be a good idea
but no that was sort of my stance and
I'd love to know what are the downside
possibilities so
you're absolutely right in your thinking
the body has a huge number of feedback
loops and when you start exogenously
meaning taking it from the outside and
in the body you can play with those
feedback loops where you start to shut
things down and the concern with
melatonin you know even at five
milligrams or even three and certainly
at 10 what we would classify that is as
a suprophysiological dose meaning that
it's a dose of a concentration that is
maybe 10 times anything that your body
would naturally release so it is a
whopping dose in that regard by the way
you've got no idea whether it's 10
milligrams or not there was a study that
looked at 30 different brands and what
they found is that based on what it said
on the bottle versus what was actually
inside of the capsules it ranged from I
think it was about 83 percent less to
478 percent more than what was stated on
the bottle because at least in the US
it's not FDA approved and just recently
maybe it was gosh three four weeks ago
there was a report
demonstrating that
melatonin overdoses that have been
reported to the US Poison Control Center
they've risen by 530 percent over the
last 10 years and what's especially
concerning is were that bump is
happening it seems to be particularly in
pediatric populations too so you know we
need to exactly keep that in mind but
coming back to your question that is far
too high of a of a dose and the concern
is about shutting down the brain's
feedback that's one of the taxes that
you could pay some people have pushed
back on sort of social media and the
internet to suggest
firstly and I think they're right that
melatonin overall in terms of its
mortality risk profile is quite low it
seems to be a somewhat safe molecule in
the sense of absolute death but that's
obviously a very extreme threshold for
you to use
people then also cite a study where they
said if you dose for high concentration
for a long period of time there was no
change in the individual's generation of
melatonin itself but if you look at that
study it's actually a case study in a
blind individual and they would dosed
with melatonin at high concentrations
for 37 days so yeah about five weeks and
sure enough by the end of that when they
withdrew the Melatonin supplementation
the individual went back to producing
the same amount of melatonin that they
produced before so you could argue from
that perspective no harm no foul the
problem is that's not how people use
melatonin people are using it for 6
months 12 months five years and
therefore I don't think we've got any
scientific data to meaningfully tell the
public that they you know should not
have these concerns in my humble opinion
too and the reason I say that you know
you can think about something like
testosterone supplementation in males
you can use supplementation and after
you know three or four months if you
stop testosterone production from the
testes themselves will
start again but there is a concern that
has to be heard between the physician
and the male who wants that prescription
that if you continue to take it long
term it may ultimately shut down the
production of testosterone and when you
stop after a long-term use six months 12
months if you don't go back to producing
your own testosterone is that true of
melatonin we don't know but the reason I
also would caution people around
melatonin I don't mean to scare manga
you know but firstly there's some really
fascinating data
in juvenile male rats where when you
give high levels of melatonin you get
testicular atrophy you get testicular
shrinkage so that is certainly a
concerned especially now we're seeing
melatonin doses in pediatric populations
it's a that's a real big concern we also
know that high doses of melatonin will
block the ability of your hippocampus to
form new synapses hippocampus is a
memory related Center and therefore it
makes it more difficult to lend you
information because you can't form brain
connections as well
so please keep that in mind I do think
though that there is you know I said
that melatonin is the Sleep timing
hormone there is one study that I looked
at where I think you could argue that
melatonin has a sleep generating benefit
above and beyond simply the timing of
your sleep which is that when you give
it in somewhat high doses in rats it's
thermoregulatory and it causes
hypothermia so not hypothermia to the
degree of Life concern but basically it
reduces core body temperature and we
know that you've got to drop your core
body temperature to get to sleep so I
think melatonin if it does have a sleep
benefit could be acting through this
root of temperature and I think that's
fascinating for me at least so
a few follow-up questions so the the
study you mentioned the case study of
the blind person where I thought that
was going and keep in mind that I know
just enough to be dangerous and throw
around words that I probably shouldn't
but if melatonin is in
sighted people
triggered in part by light signals or
light cues if you have a blind person
and again I don't know what role I
immediately think of the the super
chiasmic nucleus I think it is this
super chiasmatic nucleus that's why I
always that up God you were so
close nothing ventured nothing gained
how do you say it properly I always
screw that yeah
supraciasmatic nucleus and it refers to
the chiasma which is a Latin derivative
term meaning Crossing and it's where
your two optic nerves from your left and
right eye meat and then cross over and
reverse to the back of the brain it's
right at that fulcrum of the Cross and
it's just above it hence Supra meaning
above chiasma meaning the crossing and
the nucleus obviously so Supra
chiasmatic nucleus Supra also as in
Supra physiological so I was I'll just
call it the scn so my thinking was well
it's really
not Apples to Apples if you're comparing
a blind person to a sighted person and
it it may be that their production of
melatonin
is less affected or maybe already
handicapped to begin with in such a way
that their processing of and recovery
from melatonin Administration is just
completely different from a sighted
person I mean that wouldn't be shocking
to me at all no it's wonderful Acumen
that's exactly why we often will work
with melatonin with these patients now
it depends on the form of the nature of
blindness for example if it's blindness
because let's say that you had damage to
your the back of the head and you
damaged your visual cortex and the the
eye itself the retina is intact the
optic nerves are intact but it's the
back of the brain where you've got that
blindness disruption that can happen
there that's not necessarily a concern
because the light signals are still at
least coming down the optic nerves and
hitting the suprachiasmatic nucleus this
24 hour and the supracasmatic nucleus by
the way is where your circadian rhythm
sits it's the Master Clock the master
24-hour clock within the brain you've
got all over the body but that's the one
it's kind of one ring to rule them all
it's like the Lord of the Rings it's one
clock to rule them all that's the scn
and that still gets light in people who
have intact retina
and intact optic nerves if you don't
however you don't get the light signal
to your suprachiasmatic nucleus your
brain gets confused about is it night
time outside or is it daytime and
therefore sleep is very disrupted they
have actually what's called a free
running Sleep System where they just run
around the clock in terms of the
Circadian rhythm it's not regulated and
set to the light dark cycle hence we use
melatonin but is that you know how
normative is that case study firstly
it's one person secondly it's in someone
who has a deficit that already Alters
melatonin regulation again I I think
it's a fascinating study but I'm not
sure I put too much weight in it right
now and too much weight into a single
case study yeah I know I'm trying to be
kind but so I would I mean look I mean
case studies are important
denigrate it in any way but it's easy to
over interpret or
over apply
something like that question then
related to the the not to get too
scientific the shrinking balls
phenomenon
observed in these juvenile rats
so I'm thinking of
another thing you mentioned which is say
anabolic use or anabolic androgenic
steroid use might be getting the AAS use
exogenous use right so it could be in
the form of of testosterone replacement
cream it could be injectable
testosterone cypionate or whatever it
might be
and if used for an extended period of
time and it doesn't actually need to be
that long I mean there are certainly
anecdotal reports and case studies of
people who even after what someone might
consider a reasonably moderate cycle of
say you know eight to 12 weeks depending
on the dosage
I know one person personally who had
severely impaired testosterone
production and libido for about nine
months after a very short cycle of what
I would consider moderate dosing of some
of these these androgens
and the reason I bring that up is you
have the testes axis which is the
hypothalamic pituitary gonadal axis
right right yeah and I'm fumbling around
here but you'll see where I'm going at
this so if you interfere Upstream
or directly you inhibit as I understand
the light excels from producing
any number of things and then you have
this shrinking testicle phenomenon how
does melatonin what is the plausible
mechanism for that happening is it
disrupting sleep architecture in a
similar way that would be observed from
too little sleep and therefore you see a
decrease in testosterone what is causing
that testicle shrinkage no the study or
the study is really shows up the effects
were directly there and the testes
themselves oh nasty yeah that it was
directly altering the androgenic
benefits that would normally happen
during development during adolescent
development and it was inhibiting that
androgenic and Andrew
obviously being these the sex moments
and genetic being the promotion the
Genesis so it was inhibiting the normal
development of the testes and therefore
leading to a failure to promote them in
terms of the size and development I
think they even have now done studies
where they were showing that the seminal
tubes themselves the tubes for semen
were also impaired as a consequence of
high doses of melatonin as well I could
have that wrong now in high doses if
we're looking at you know since rats
aren't always little humans but when we
say high dose are we are the sort of
migs per kegs of like milligrams per
kilogram comparable to what a human
would be consuming if they are taking
let's assume the dosing is accurate on
the bottle just for the sake of
Simplicity yeah eight milligrams 10
milligrams or would it be a human
equivalent of someone who say
being 160 pounds taking 160 milligrams
of melatonin do you have any idea what
the
comparable would be it's difficult to
look at those ratios if you try to match
the paper in part because of the
administration or the administration and
because it's direct Administration
rather than going through sort of
hepatic clearance and the stomach and
all of that stuff so it's going to be
tricky I think to do the one-to-one
transformation certainly what we found
with studies if you are looking for a
melatonin sleep benefit there was one
paper that demonstrated probably the
optimal dose is somewhere between about
0.3 to 0.5
milligrams of melatonin now if you go
onto the Internet it's going to be very
difficult for you to get something even
as low as one milligram and here we're
talking about you know maybe half of
that dose of concentration most you're
lucky if you can find three milligrams
most will be five milligrams or 10
milligrams that's the whopping dose that
we're we're talking about here
stuff man what a mess humans man we make
such a mess it's just like remember when
they're like carrots are good for this
let's isolate beta-carotene and mega
dose that oops yeah sorry about that
let's just say over and over again if we
could keep on the
sort of unconventional let's just say
tips perspective side of things if you
don't mind
I would love to talk about and this is
something that I haven't discussed with
you at any length
the art of minimizing sleep time
and this may tie into cbti which I
really don't know that much about but I
like a lot of people I think have
made the error although it doesn't feel
like an error of getting into bed and
even if my sleep onset takes an hour
hour and a half because maybe I have
that tired and wired feeling which a lot
of people do a lot of veterans people
with PTSD you know suffer from this
overly activated sympathetic nervous
system which I do a lot and I'll just
stay in bed right even if it takes me
three hours to get to sleep I will often
just kind of sit there and try to
meditate my way into Oblivion which
doesn't always work very well so what's
the what's the counter approach yeah so
I think you know one of the the sort of
the conventional tips for sleep you can
find all over the Internet and you know
idiots like me you can hear speaking
about the five tips of beta sleep
hygiene and you know there's very good
evidence for why those are sensible
things to put in place but what about
the unconventional and one of the
unconventional components is to limit
your sleep times you said there is the
principle
the principal treatment for insomnia
should not be the first line defense of
sleeping pills that we discussed in the
last episode the current recommendation
is something called cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia or cbti and as you
can tell by the term it works on two
things cognitive things in other words
your thoughts and your beliefs about
sleep and then your behaviors what are
you not doing that you should do to help
your sleep and what are you doing that
you shouldn't be doing and you should
stop doing to help your sleep and that's
the cbti component
probably if you look across the studies
and cbti has a number of different
features in this treatment this therapy
approach
but one of the most potent tools in the
box of the cbti therapist is sleep what
we call Sleep restriction therapy which
sounds paradoxical you come to me let's
say I'm your sleep clinician you say I
am not sleeping well I'm in bed for
about eight hours but I think I only
maybe sleep for four four and a half
hours I'm just not getting enough sleep
can you help me and my response to you
is excellent I've got a great treatment
for you it's called Sleep restriction
therapy and you hear the kind of the
record scratch and you say hang on a
second I just told you I'm not getting
enough sleep and you're telling me we're
going to restrict my sleep it's actually
a poorly termed phrase it should really
be called bedtime restriction therapy
and it works in the following way that
right now if you take that example
you're in bed for eight hours and you're
sleeping for four hours you have a
miserable sleep efficiency so you have a
sleep efficiency of 50 half of the
amount of time that you're in bed you're
awake half the time you're asleep we
want to see that around about 85 or
greater in terms of your sleep
efficiency that's what we think is
healthy
and so
rather than actually having you stay in
bed for any longer we do the opposite
and we use the biology of your brain and
something called Sleep pressure so from
the moment that both you and I woke up
we've been building up a chemical that
we've sort of discussed with regarding
caffeine which was adenosine
adenosine builds up the sleepier and
sleepier you feel and the longer that
you're awake the heavier that weight of
sleepiness will be weighing you down so
just take the extreme of let's say you
pull an all-nighter or you're awake for
36 hours imagine how tired you are at
that point when you get into bed that
following night it's almost as though
nothing's going to stop you earthquakes
wildfires you you're just going to get
into bed and you're going to be knocked
out why because you've just got so much
sleepiness built up so much adenosine
that hasn't been removed so we do a
diluted version of that in cpti with
sleep restriction therapy where we say
okay you're going to bed just for
argument's sake at midnight and you're
waking up at eight now what I want you
to do is actually compress that window
of time and I want you to go to bed not
at midnight but now push it go to 2 A.M
or 2 30 a.m or let's say 3 A.M but you
still wake up at the same time so where
we restrict your sleep is not by having
you wake up any earlier which is kind of
miserable than most people like most
people feel it's easier to go to bed
later than wake up any earlier so we
start there we limit the amount of time
that you're in bed and we restrict it
down to maybe six hours or five hours
and the next day you're going to feel
miserable you know you've only been in
bed for five hours
but what happens is that as long as you
commit to it and it has to be committed
and you have to work with someone who's
going to motivate you and it is hard but
it works
and after the second night of being in
bed for five hours you've been awake for
longer so now you've been awake for 19
hours during the day and you're only in
bed assuming for five hours
and that increase in your adenosine
because you're awake now for 19 hours
straight for one day for a second day
for a third day it all starts to
accumulate
and then at one point maybe and it
depends on the patient let's say about
four or five days after that they get
into bed at 2 30 a.m or 3 A.M and then
the next thing that they remember is
their alarm going off at 8am and for the
first time ever they have slept all the
way through from front to back now in
that example I've restricted the Bedtime
by three hours
and they're now sleeping a solid five
hours but remember that's better than
where they were they were in bed for
eight hours and they were only sleeping
for four hours so I've added an extra
hour and they're in bed for less time
and then gradually what we do is we
start to back that up once you're stable
and your your sleep efficiency is 85 90
then we'll say okay now go to bed at 2AM
and then now let's go to bed at 1 30 a.m
and now let's try 1am and gradually we
back it off and essentially it's like
hitting the reset button on your Wi-Fi
router you are retraining the Sleep
System and in doing so you can start to
get people's confidence renewed because
that's a big problem with insomnia I
mean I was gonna say it sounds like more
than anything well I shouldn't say that
what the hell am I but it seems like
principle among the reasons that would
work is that you are resetting sleep
related anxiety
hundred percent because when you are
suffering from insomnia and I've had my
bouts too and I know that you know
you've spoken publicly about
struggles before
you go into the bedroom and the bed just
looks like the enemy and you have lost
all confidence in your ability to sleep
and at that point your sleep controls
you
but by way of cbti and sleep restriction
therapy you turn the tables now you
control your sleep not your sleep
controlling you and you regain
confidence that is a huge win I can't
tell you how big that is for people with
insomnia it's a terrible fear when they
go into the bedroom they just convince
themselves it's not going to be my night
so does that sort of help I know it's a
long explanation it does help yeah it's
a little bit like working out you know
if I go to the gym for an hour and for
the most part you know I'm probably only
working out for maybe 40 or 30 minutes
because I'm looking my phone I'm
chatting to people checking social media
whatever it is and so you're only really
working out for 40 of those minutes it's
not an efficient workout but now my gym
says I'm sorry we're limiting it to 30
minutes every day you've got no more
time than that after a couple of days I
don't have the choice I'm thinking I'm
not getting my workouts in so I put my
phone on silent turn it off and I just
go in there and I hit the gym hard and I
work out for 30 minutes straight my
efficiency has improved
so let's segue and I'll let you choose
how you want to bridge things to lucid
dreaming and we can do it in a few steps
if necessary in part because when I
reflect on the periods of best sleep
let's just say past
adolescence or early adolescents
some of my best periods of sleep and I
could unpack what I mean by best but
easiest lowest stress periods have been
when I have focused on inducing lucidity
because instead of dreading sleep I end
up looking forward to sleep and it
turned everything on its head now the
downside is we might get to this
there's quite a bit of training required
and things need to be a bit regimented
in my experience but how would you like
to move to lucid dreaming including a
definition of of lucid dreaming I think
perhaps what we could do is start with
what basic dreaming is and yes what it
is perhaps psychologically
neurologically from the level of the
brain because neurological is important
when we try to understand what lucid
dreaming is and how it's different to
standard dreaming
and we can also touch on the functional
benefits of dreaming but maybe we could
leave that aside I think we spoke a
little bit about that before in the
first episode but from a psychological
level dreaming
I mean it's pretty ridiculous when you
think about it because last night you
and I when we went to sleep and we
started dreaming we became completely
psychotic
and before you reject that sort of
diagnosis of my nighttime psychosis I'll
give you five good reasons when we dream
we start to see things which are not
there so you're hallucinating
you also believe things that couldn't
possibly be true so you're delusional
you get very confused about time and
place and sometimes also person as well
so you're suffering from disorientation
you often have these wildly
pendulum-like almost fluctuations in
your emotions and it's what
psychiatrists will call being
effectively label or emotionally labile
and then how great you and I both woke
up this morning and we forgot most if
not all of that dream experience so
we're suffering from amnesia
and if you you know if you were to
experience any one of those five things
while you're awake you probably would be
seeking some form of psychiatric
intervention but for reasons that we're
now only starting to understand when it
comes to the functions of dreaming it's
it's a perfectly normal biological and
psychological process
the biological process is utterly
interesting we and others have done
studies where we've been putting people
inside of brain scanners and we let them
go through the different stages of sleep
and we let them go into REM sleep now
dreaming if you use a loose definition
which is with the report of any mental
activity upon Awakening if you use that
loose definition you dream in almost
every stage of sleep but what most
people think of when you say Dreaming or
REM sleep dreams those are the emotional
The Narrative the bizarre the strange
that's really the state from which you
dream and when we look at that sleep
stage inside of the MRI scanner firstly
vast swaths of the visual cortex start
lighting up in your brain the motor
regions of the brain erupt in activity
emotional sensors of the brain become
active as well as memory centers of the
brain and in fact some parts of your
brain are up to 30 more active when
you're in dream sleep than when you're
awake which is stunning to me because we
often think of sleep as just this
passive non-conscious state
metabolically from the brain perspective
it's wild
but the freakish part is what happens to
another region of your brain called the
prefrontal cortex and particularly the
left and the right side which sits just
above your eyes
and it's particularly a region called
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex left
and right side of the frontal lobe that
part of the brain normally when it's
active acts like the CEO of the brain
but it makes high level sort of
executive top-down control decisions and
it allows you to have not just rational
decisions but volitional decisions in
other words you're choosing to make that
choice and you're choosing to do that
action that's part of the prefrontal
cortex job
that part of the brain goes offline when
we go into REM sleep your dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex doesn't erupt with
activity like many of these other
regions it is suppressed in its activity
and that I think is our current
explanation as to why your dreams are so
visual so motoric filled with past
memories them
also just highly emotional but they're
utterly bizarre utterly erratic and you
have no volitional control the the
prison guards have left the building and
the prisoners are running a mark your
prefrontal cortex is down and so that's
one of the fascinating parts of dream
sleep neurologically as well as the body
by the way
I think we probably didn't discuss this
before but when you go into dream sleep
your brain paralyzes your body
you are completely limp so if I were to
come into the to the bedroom and just
pick you up during REM sleep you would
be like a rag doll all of your skeletal
muscles are inhibited
and people don't need to worry by the
way your involuntary skeletal muscles
that control your respiration in your
heart they're not affected but all of
your voluntary muscles are because your
brain stem which is where the REM and
non-rem mechanisms play out
not only does it beam an activating
signal up into the dreaming brain it
sends one down the spinal cord and it
paralyzes what's called the Alpha motor
neurons of the spinal cord that control
your voluntary skeletal muscles so you
are locked into a physical incarceration
during REM sleep during dream sleep
which by the way explains something
called REM sleep paralysis upon
Awakening and adequately explains most
alien abductions but we don't need to go
there we can we can always move on to
what's different about dreaming when it
comes to Lucidity and or just pause
there and go into anything that comes to
mind now let's jump into lucid dreaming
I'm ready
and I do want to talk about tracking of
time or perception of time at some point
yes yeah but I think we can do that
vis-a-vis lucid dreaming because I have
some questions let's jump into lucid
dreaming yeah lucid dreaming it used to
be a complete show it's in science you
know back in the 60s and the 70s to
suggest that you could gain control over
a normally non-volutional process only
added insults to the idiotic
nature of this thing called sleep and
Dreaming by itself and now you're
telling me okay we've got these things
called dreams and also you claim to be
able to control them and do whatever you
like in them really I you know show me
some good science but now we have some
Exquisite science and it's not even
debated anymore it's not a charlatan
science
and the first experiments actually come
back to our first topic which was sleep
and sex the first experiments used
orgasm and ejaculation as the test
so with a lucid dreamer when they are
asleep just like you and I when we're
not lucid dreaming they are paralyzed so
they've got no good way to tell you okay
I'm now lucid and they have no way to
tell you what I'm dreaming about and
what's happening except that they do
which is their eyes because one of the
two muscle groups that is spurred from
the voluntary skeletal paralysis of your
muscles are the extra ocular muscles
that move your eyes up and down and left
and right and that's why by the way you
still have rapid eye movements during
REM sleep because those muscles are not
inhibited
so we can now generate essentially a
language between me the experimenter and
you the Lucid dreamer which is like a an
ocular Morse code
and you can be telling me using
predefined
eye movement instructions what's going
on so at the moment you become Lucid
you've gone into dream sleep and I can
see that in the next door sleep Control
Center and then all of a sudden I see
based on your eye movement traces that
I'm measuring you do three deliberate
flicks to the left and that's your
signal to me that me the participant I'm
now Lucid okay great now then you're
going to do
two big circular movements to the right
and that's you saying in my dream I'm
now clenching my right hand and then
moving your eyes circular to the left
that's me moving my left hand
and so you can be telling me every time
that you're doing something in your
dream what it is that you're doing which
is just I mean could you imagine who
this and then if you're like if you like
that trick now watch me ejaculate well
that was exactly what they did so then
they said okay you claim to be able to
because
when you control lucid dreaming by the
way the definition is just that you
are aware that you're dreaming as you're
dreaming that's our basic scientific
definition but what most people in the
late public think of as lucid dreaming
it's not just that you know that you're
dreaming you take control of your dreams
and of course if you can control your
dreams one of the things that people
enjoy doing is you know having sex and
having an orgasm all they're gonna do
that's all they're gonna do yeah exactly
orgy everywhere it was the original
Dreamscape pornography you know forget
PornHub you just had to lose a dream
heavier lift but yeah it is but you know
I could argue it's well worth it and so
we've got these experiments now and by
the way we've done Imaging studies that
are less messy for the experimenter to
provide but I should come I should
explain that by the way people would
then say okay I'm now starting to have
sex and I'm now just about to have an
orgasm and then they would say I've just
had my orgasm and you can go into the
room and sure enough with males
especially you've got proof positive
data that what they said was real and
hence you've just scientifically proven
lucid dreaming is it's great we've got
much more sophisticated MRI scanning
methods now and I I won't bore you with
the cities but it's very clear that we
know that lucid dreaming is real the
next question then was how
how do people lucid dream what is the
underlying neural mechanism yeah and
this comes back to the prefrontal cortex
and those dorsal lateral prefrontal
parts of the the brain which are the
volitional control centers which go
offline what we found is that activity
both the electrical activity and also
when you put people in Scanners the
Imaging activity in those regions starts
to ramp back up again as if when you
become lucid
you regain your rational logical control
over the dream state and so the
prefrontal cortex gives you that
capacity to take back what you lost
which is volition
there was a study recently however that
I think did a pretty good job to say
that may not be the case that some of
those uh results are confounded by the
method of the analysis and the method of
the recording so I think it's the jury
is still a little bit out but even in
that study they demonstrated that
there's something about their brain
waves that is radically different at
that fulcrum point where they shift from
going from non-lucid dreaming to lucid
dreaming it's not a question of if it's
just how
what is the jury still out on I'm sorry
I missed that so the jury is still out
on this idea that the electrical
bursting brainwave activity is recapit
comes back online over the prefrontal
cortex and what they were finding is
that it's potentially an artifact of the
eye movements that start to happen so
the eye movements when you're moving
those muscles those extra ocular muscles
you move muscles using electrical
impulses and those electrical impulses
that are coming from the eye will also
bleed up into the brain and when you get
all of this frenetic eye movement it
starts to masquerade as if it's the
prefrontal cortex which sits directly
above them as getting re-engaged and
hence when you control for that you
don't see as powerful an argument for
the re-engagement of the prefrontal
cortex what is your personal experience
if any with lucid dreaming unfortunately
I am not a
common Lucid dreamer it's happened
probably about two or three times in my
life
and when it's happened it's immensely
pleasurable have I tried to
curate it develop it and use different
techniques and we can speak about the
current techniques that are out there in
the science I have not chosen to do that
and it's not necessarily because I see
in the science anything to be worried
about
I can Steel Man both sides of that
argument we know that only about 10 to
20 percent of the population are natural
lucid dreamers
and you could argue from an evolutionary
standpoint that lucid dreaming is so
adaptive so beneficial to us Homo
sapiens then the reverse would be true
that mother nature would have heavily
selected it and 80 to 90 of the
population would be lucid dreamers but I
can push back on my own argument because
there's a desperate flaw in that logic
that argument assumes that we've stopped
evolving and we haven't right so maybe
that 10 to 20 percent of natural lucid
dreamers are the Forefront of hominid
Evolution and we don't need to be
worried about AI we need to be worried
about the the lucid dreamers becoming
the next Super race of you know Humanity
so
I wrestle between those two if it's that
volume though that 80 to 90 of people
don't naturally do it at this stage of
after 3.6 million years of of evolution
of homily development my sense is that
do I think that I understand better than
Mother Nature's blueprint exactly what I
should be serving up in my dreams at
night to get all of the benefits of
dreams and by the way we know that
dreaming above and beyond REM sleep
itself serves a number of key different
functions like emotional therapy and
emotional first aid it supports
creativity
and I I've worried myself is it hubris
for me to think that I should then take
the reins and get into the the driver's
cockpit and start steering the vehicle
rather than just allowing whatever
Mother Nature thinks should happen for
me I don't know the only other strike
against lucid dreaming and I don't think
it's a big one and I don't think it's
anything to be worried about when you
survey people and when we've examined
people who claim to be lucid dreamers on
a night after lucid dreaming they
typically report that their sleep is
less restorative and less refreshing
they find it to be perhaps more mentally
fatiguing
but I don't think that's really a big
second night the subsequent night of
sleep no sorry the next morning when
they wake up after the night when they
have had lucid dreaming they find that
it was more fatiguing perhaps because
it's more effortful because you're
engaging the prefrontal cortex
that's one argument but I don't think
that's a particularly good argument to
say that if you are a lucid dreamer you
need to be worried or if you want a
lucid dream you should not engage in
some of the different methods that we've
developed to improve it
I'm curious what the state of the art is
from a scientific perspective because
people may hear the term lucid dreaming
and think that it is a relatively new
construct slash exercise of the human
mind but that's not true at all at least
I mean for thousands of years and you
know Tibetan practices and elsewhere
exactly have been elaborate descriptions
of training and philosophical and
cosmological implications of this type
of sleep engineering let's call it so
what are the predominant methods of or
for inducing Lucidity in these studies
or that you've seen covered in the
literature I'm very curious
yeah right now in terms of the science
we probably have two methods that have
been put out that have some degree of
validity to them although I would say
that when you look at each one of the
papers the statistical robustness in
terms of the reliability of these things
it's not especially High I mean some of
these techniques do gain statistical
significance meaning that when you try
them it does significantly from a
statistical perspective increase your
likelihood of lucid dreaming
the first one is called it's called the
mild method for short but it stands for
the mnemonic induction of lucid dreaming
m-i-l-d method and essentially it's
pretty simple that you create a
conscious and very deliberate intention
to remember that you're dreaming and
usually this is pre-bed that you're
lying there before you go to sleep and
you start repeating this intention I am
going to deliberately remember that I am
dreaming as I am dreaming and you keep
doing that night after night over and
over again and it sounds hokey it sounds
really quite you know science lite light
but the evidence is suggesting it's in
favor I think the other one that's
probably more popular is called the
reality testing method and it's oh gosh
it's it was popularized at least I think
it was popularized and it's even liberge
no Stephen Laberge was a fascinating
researcher who was working here in the
Bay Area in the 1980s and 90s who
probably was really the pioneer of
modern day lucid dreaming and then at
some point he was doing academic you
know really interesting scientific
studies and then he moved away and he
developed his own Lucidity Institute and
sort of was selling CDs to how to do
that and so I think it went off in a
slightly strange Direction and I don't
know what came of him but the reality
testing method actually came to fruition
on many people's Radars with a brilliant
movie called Waking Life by Richard
linklater have you seen this it's great
it is a if people and maybe we can link
to it in the show notes if people
haven't watched it don't worry if you're
not interested in lucid dreaming yes the
movie revolves around lucid dreaming but
the philosophy and the conversations
will blow your mind it is one of my
favorites and the visual treatment of
the movie oh is so clever it's so cool
isn't it genius and maybe we won't oil
for people who haven't seen it but the
idea of the reality testing method is
that during the waking day you start to
test reality in a way that you don't
normally do so let's say that I would
walk over to the table that I'm sitting
next to here and I press my hand down on
the table and the table is resisting my
hand just like the waking laws of
physics would predict or I go over to
the wall and I switch on the light
switch so the lights go on and when I
turn them off do they go off and hence I
understand that I'm probably in
conscious waking reality
and you start doing this throughout your
entire waking day to the point where it
becomes a reflexive habit and then the
hope is that that habit bleeds through
into your dreaming life from your Waking
Life and you start to do the same
reality testing in dreams and then all
of a sudden I press my hand down on the
table and it moves all the way through
the table to the other side and at that
point I think oh The Jig Is up I'm not
awake I'm dreaming and then you gain
Lucidity does that sort of
yeah no it does actually if you don't
mind me just because I don't think I've
discussed this at any real length in any
podcast but this was a
a very strong focus of mine for a part
of like the last two years of high
school and then I Revisited it a few
years later in college and one might ask
if you enjoy it so much why the break
and the break is because there's
training involved and I do suggest this
is an oldie but goodie I'm sure there
are actually I know there are many many
books that have been published since but
exploring the world of lucid dreaming by
Stephen liberge b-e-r-g-e I'm probably
mispronouncing the last name because I
can't speak French but that book lays
out the mild technique that you
mentioned and the reality testing and
I'd love to just give folks an idea
perhaps a few stories and these are yes
anecdotal and of one so but I hope them
to be perhaps inspiring in a sense so
number one I do not count myself among
the people who are natural lucid
dreamers at all I think most people have
had the experience of lucid dreaming oh
my God I became conscious I was dreaming
and then I immediately woke up or went
back into non-lucid dreaming most people
have had that experience and I'd had
that experience who knows much like you
maybe two or three times scattered over
a very long period of time but then I
read Stephen's book and step one is
practicing dream recall and putting
together a dream journal and there are a
number of reasons for this but one of
the reasons is to identify
good candidates recurring patterns that
you can use as cues for your reality
testing and waking life so for instance
if you identify and your dream recall
improves dramatically when you begin to
journal in this way immediately upon
waking you can't check your phone you
can't brush your teeth you need to just
roll over and immediately do this and I
do not think voice memo Works nearly as
well because you'll go back and reread
this skeleton outline of fragments and
that will prompt further recollection
and you can fill in the blanks and that
that is a productive way of approaching
it you might identify that you walk
through many doorways for instance or
for whatever reason you end up in areas
where you see grass or perhaps you see
you look at your watch often in dreams
at which point you would identify as
those as candidates for this reality
testing that you were referring to
or you could simply have an alarm after
you've started doing the stream recall
and at random points in the day you have
to do a reality test and I'll just give
a couple of recommendations for folks so
the first is if the reality test
is hard to
precisely convincingly test
it may not translate to dream so what I
mean by that is a lot of folks when
they're starting this they'll say well I
will try to fly
and yes you can fly in dreams and I
wasn't kidding earlier when I said the
people just go complete nymphomaniac
generally when people first gain the
ability to intermittently induce
Lucidity they're just everything
and they're flying everywhere those are
the two things that everybody does
and that's fine but if during your
Waking Life it's like you have lunch and
then the alarm goes off and you're like
let me a reality test how are you really
going to attempt to fly in a convincing
compelling way but there are other
options for instance
and yeah who knows I mean science can be
expensive and who knows if these studies
will ever get done but or how they would
even be done but what I think
experienced lucid dreamers will probably
corroborate is that if you look at a
pattern let's just say you have
long tiles that are that have one
orientation in a restaurant
and you look away from them and look
back at them in reality they stay the
same
in a dream state they very often almost
always reorient because your mind is
reconstructing that pattern if that
makes sense and similarly if you look at
say a digital clock readout
something like that the numbers will not
be the same the time will change right
and just for the Practical applications
here yeah you can have fun doing stuff
but at the end of high school I was
going to be competing at a national
level in wrestling and so I would
actually train
with this uh this coach from Oklahoma
John Smith who had never met still
haven't ever met and I would actually do
Drilling in lucid dreams and again and
of one who knows but I really seem to
discern a translation of that added
practice time to the in-world practice
so to speak it's a fascinating
experience I encourage everybody to try
it out but it is a commitment it's it's
quite a commitment it's kind of like if
you want to control your anger and you
want to have a pattern interrupt and you
need to develop that over time and
to take something that is subconscious
and make it conscious does take some
time
and I think that it's fascinating that
last spot that you said were when you
were working with the coach that you
truly actually never worked with but you
saw it translate to the mat in the
waking real world I think it fits very
well with the idea of what one of the
functions of dreaming which is this
notion of abstract creativity of problem
solving and we know that it's during the
dreams that it's during deep non-rem
sleep when we take individual memories
that we've been learning and we cement
them and we essentially hit the save
button on them and we sort of concretize
them in the neural architecture of the
brain but it's during dream sleep that
we take those newly freshly minted
memories and we start to interconnect
and Associate them with this vast
catalog of previous knowledge that we
have so that you start to Divine
solutions to previously impenetrable
problems and the reason that happens is
not because the dreaming brain is
designed to build the obvious
connections it's seems to do a Google
search gone wrong where it takes the new
information it inserts it and it
immediately puts you to page 20. so
maybe I type in you know the Tim Ferriss
show and it takes me immediately to some
field hockey game in Utah and I think
hang on a second how on Earth is that
related but if I look there is a distant
non-obvious connection and this is what
the dreaming brain and perhaps the lucid
dreaming brain is particularly good at
it starts to fuse things together that
shouldn't normally go together but when
they do because marked advances in
evolutionary Fitness and it's the
biological basis of creativity and so I
think what's happening with that
description that you mentioned is that
you're waking up in terms of your skills
and your motor skills but also happens
with knowledge with a revised mind-wide
web of associations it's almost like
informational alchemy that happens at
night
and that's why you can have these
remarkable stories of people you know
solving problems and coming up with
Incredible Creative Solutions and
wonderful pieces of Art and music and
literature have all been inspired by way
of dream creative insight and I think
that's perhaps in part why you you were
feeling good about that benefit is there
are certain ways that you were you know
performing skills and movements that you
just couldn't see when you're awake but
when you go into the dream state and you
force that to be on the menu of the
dreaming
sort of digestion at night then all of a
sudden the dreaming brain was taking
what you were learning and coming up
with these novel new insights so I think
it fits very well with what we know
about one of the functions of dreaming
and it's the reason that you've probably
never been told to stay awake on a
problem
yeah and I've not experienced the
subsequent fatigue which I think would
have been at least for me very obvious
because I was training every day and so
I I think I would have subjectively
noticed a decrease in performance
and I will just put a call out to the
audience if if anyone out there is aware
of someone who is The Heir Apparent or
maybe he the version two version three
or or not but of Stephen liberge but
somebody who is really taking lucid
dreaming seriously the different
techniques for induction perhaps looking
at the interplay of sleep nutrition
other variables on inducing Lucidity
please let me know on Twitter at T
Ferris t-f-e-r-r-i-s-s because I am
deeply interested in this and I remember
back in the day when I was at school I
mean this was in the 90s but some of
Steven's acolytes were experimenting
with things like actually I was
experimenting with huperzine a but
others were experimenting with things
like galantomy and all these various
supplements in the hopes that they would
increase the frequency of
inducing Lucidity and there are some
devices out there right now where people
have sort of tried to have these
ocular devices where they start to sort
of flash light into the eyes and the
reason they use the ocular device is
that the device itself can measure some
parts of the brainwave activity it can
measure the eye movements it senses when
you go into dream sleep and then it
begins sort of the flashing and the hope
is that that flushing is an instigating
trigger to build Lucidity and make you a
word that you're dreaming
you know I've seen no data on how
effective those are scientifically but
people are trying to take this to the
next level people have played around
with compounds they're now playing
around with technology
yeah so I'm gonna give some further
unsolicited thoughts that will no doubt
just be very bothersome because they're
they're not based on any data to speak
of other than my personal experience and
also having read a number of books and
different reports and gone on all these
crazy forums but experientially and this
could be pure placebo effect but for
most folks when they realize they're
dreaming it's like oh my God I'm
dreaming and then they snap right out of
it either they wake up or they go right
back into normal Ram sleep let's just
say for whatever reason looking at your
hands or spinning attempting to spin
like do you like to spin and play as
much like you would
physically seems to help extend the the
session of Lucidity so to speak again no
no studies to cite no hard data to point
to but for people who want to screw
around with it there you go so it's free
advice it may be worth what you pay for
it
if we go from here perhaps to segue to
learning and memory and I know that
you're very deeply familiar with
research as it relates to sleep
different phases of sleep and
various aspects of cognition including
memory
if one wanted to
optimize for learning now they're
different types of learning right you
could have procedural knowledge like
riding a bike or skill acquisition like
my case the wrestling they could have
declarative knowledge more data driven
memorizing Chinese characters is one
that I've thought about a lot how would
you suggest people think about
sleep and are there ways to optimize for
learning or skill acquisition aside from
ensuring that your sleep is just not
broken in some fundamental way
I think what we've started to understand
is that different stages of sleep do
different things for different systems
of memory at different times of night so
it's not yes the story is simple that
you need sleep for learning and memory
but there is evidence that we can
pattern match what type of things that
you're learning with a particular stage
of sleep if you wanted to try to dial it
up if we were so you know replete a
scientist to have dials like a mixing
deck where we could instantly say okay
tonight you want more stage two non-rem
sleep oh you want more spindles you want
more deep sleep I mean we're getting
there with brain stimulation the dead
mouse DJ of exactly yeah maybe I should
grab that Twitter handle already
certainly what we know from a bigger
perspective is that you firstly you've
got to get sleep before learning to
prepare your brain for the initial Act
of imprinting and learning new
information and we've done some studies
where we've deprived people of sleep and
that night of deprivation you know
should you pull the all-nighter is it a
wise idea and the answer is no because
you're about 20 to 40 percent deficient
in your learning ability which I when
you have not been getting sufficient
sleep
which I do think is interesting when you
consider what's happening to sleep in
our education populations right now but
I can put that aside
we also know why that's the case we did
a study where we were looking at the
brain trying to learn information with
and without sleep inside an MRI scanner
and there's a structure that we've
spoken about before called the
hippocampus which sits on the left and
the right side of your brain and it's
almost like the inbox for memory the
informational inbox that it grabs new
memories
and when you don't have sleep that
hippocampal structure it's almost like
it becomes waterlogged as it were and
you can't absorb new information no it's
just coming back to the inbox analogy I
suppose it's almost like the inbox is
full and you just start bouncing those
incoming mails you don't commit the
experience to memory because what we
discovered is that the hippocampus is
shut down and so no wonder you can't
imprint that new information
we also found that if you want to
reverse that Trend and say how can I
increase my learning capacity we did a
nap study during the day and what we
found is that it's not just sleep but
it's a particular bursting electrical
brain wave called a sleep spindle and
the more of those sleep spindles that
you are having the greater the
restoration of your learning ability so
the way we did the study we took group
of people and we had them try and learn
a whole set of information at midday and
then we brought them back and then at 6
PM we had them learn an additional new
set of information and so we could
simply compare what's your learning
capacity at time point one versus time
point two but then half of the subjects
had a nap in the middle of that six hour
period the others did not nap they
remained awake and there was a deviation
there was a separation such that those
people who nabbed they actually had a
restoration of their learning ability
those people who didn't had a
deterioration in their learning ability
and the greater the number of spindles
during the nap these sleep spindles that
happened during what we call non-rapid
eye movement sleep the greater the
refreshment and the recuperation of
their learning ability
how long were the Naps so the Naps there
were 90 minutes in duration now I
wouldn't recommend that for most people
is that a like a ultradian rhythm or is
that oh you are yeah yes I mean you're
you're close with supercharismatic
nucleus you're going on with the old
tradian so old trading some yeah simply
means it's shorter than a day
and circadian when we describe it it
means approximately or around a day's
length ultradian shorter than a day and
yes you're in human beings are sleep
cycle going from non-rem to REM which we
repeat is every 90 minutes now that's in
US human beings it's different across
different species our sleep cycle is
actually quite long relative to others
for example Birds may just have a
non-rem to REM cycle of about two
minutes which is very very short they
flip back and forth was 90 minutes and
so usually when we do these nap studies
we give the brain the opportunity to
cycle through both non-rem and REM so
then we give the sleeping brain the
chance to say look this is the stage of
sleep where you're going to see the
correlation with the benefit that you
measure when you wake that individual up
so we want to give REM and non-rem an
equal opportunity to show their prowess
in transact a functional benefit for the
brain that's why we usually do 90
minutes but if you're trying to optimize
napping I should probably do a podcast
on this myself on the optimal version of
napping the short and longer of it is
nap for about 15 to 20 minutes and no
longer because when you nap for longer
what happens is that you start to go
down into the deeper stages of non-rem
and then when you wake up after 30 or 40
minutes you're coming out of the deepest
stage of sleep and you have what's
called Sleep inertia which feels like a
sleep hangover and it's even worse when
you wake up than it was before you took
the nap so but if you do 15 to 20
minutes you don't get that heavy hit of
sleep inertia but you still get sleep
benefits once you get to sort of down to
about nine eight or seven minutes we
really don't see brain or Body Benefits
getting to 15 to 20 you get some nice
cognitive benefits but you lose the
downside of the Sleep inertia effect
but I'm digressing so that's sort of the
sleep before learning you also need
sleep after learning however to then
take those new memories and as we
mentioned before to sort of
fixate them into the neural architecture
of the brain it's like it is like
hitting the save button but the problem
is it's not digital in your word
document which happens in milliseconds
the saving of memories in the brain is
an organic process it requires the
building of new proteins between your
synapses so it takes hours but it takes
hours not just during wake but during
sleep
and there what we found is that it's
during deep non-rem sleep or deep
non-repid eye movement sleep that the
brain will
cement those new memories it's almost
like that scene in Jurassic Park where
the Amber is fixated the fly you know
for in perpetuity and Sleep Future
proofs the information within your brain
and this perhaps comes on to both the
mechanism but also the idea of time that
we discussed or that we should discuss
perhaps yeah could I pause before we get
to time just to ask about the
neuroanatomical or
plausible mechanisms for ongoing need
for sleep in order to have accurate
recall later now I may be misremembering
this but when I read your book one of
these studies that seemed to hop out to
me maybe I was having a fever dream so
please correct me but it was looking at
sleep deprivation at different points
after initial acquisition of
knowledge so you had students who were
studying
and this may have been alcohol related
as well so you'll have to clarify for me
but one might think sleep before
learning important yes of course sleep
say the night after learning important
yes but as I recall it was something
like three days later if you interrupted
the sleep
whether by deprivation or alcohol
that you subsequently saw lower recall
scores something like that am I
inventing this no your memory is
pinpoint accurate so your sleep is not
perhaps quite as bad as well yeah you're
right so we've done these to these and
there are perhaps two cities that speak
to your point one of the studies
you have people learn some information
and then you deprive them of sleep the
first night after learning
but then you don't test them you give
them all of the recovery sleep that they
want on a second night and a third night
and then you test them
and what we find is that the memory
recollection is still impaired out on
day five
so in other words if you don't sleep
within the first 24 hours after learning
you lose the chance to consolidate those
memories so sleep for memory is an All
or Nothing phenomenon and you know if
you're not snoozing that first night
you're losing and no amount of recovery
sleep on the second or the third night
was going to salvage the process because
it seems as though that there is a
selective time window of opportunity for
consolidation and if you miss it
unfortunately it's gone so in that way
sleep isn't like the bank that you can't
accumulate that debt and then try to pay
it off at a later point in time that was
the first study then there was another
study done by Carlisle Smith a great
memory researcher
we didn't do the study but I I'm so
jealous because it's such a brilliant
study he was looking at different forms
of sort of Creative Learning which we
know is more dependent on REM sleep
learning facts textbook information and
saving that stuff that's about deep
non-rem sleep and we can speak about the
mechanisms when it comes to integrating
and associating the information as we
spoke about that's more about REM sleep
so he did a very clever study he knew
that one of the major consequences of
alcohol's disruption on your sleep is
not just that it sedates you not just
that it fragments your sleep but it's
very potent at blocking your dream sleep
and the reason is because of the
aldehydes the metabolic byproduct and
something called
acetaldehyde is the main reason that
your REM sleep is demolished by way of
alcohol and he was very interested in
this idea because we knew at the time
that REM sleep dreaming REM sleep
dreaming was associated with this type
of creative memory so he took a group of
individuals and he separated them into
about four or five different groups
and everyone learned this information on
the first day which required them to
sort of create it was actually very much
like learning a novel language it was an
abstract analogical language almost like
learning a computer code that's
completely foreign to you and it's not
just about learning the individual
pieces it's understanding the
grammatical rules of this big picture
structure associative
so they learned it on day one and then
out on day seven they tested those
individuals so they learned it without
any alcohol in the system and then they
were tested seven days later without any
alcohol in the system but here was the
clever twist one group across those
subsequent six nights they slept
normally with no alcohol the second
group the first night after learning
that information they got them
essentially just to the point of
inebriation to about the point of being
blood alcohol illegal you know point
zero eight percent and it was body
standardized dose across individuals so
you had one group the control group the
second group they got a little bit tipsy
on night one and then the subsequent
night they were alcohol-free then there
was a third group of individuals who had
they learned on day one sober then they
had natural sleep the first night no
drinking then they had natural sleep the
second night and no drinking and then on
the third night that's when they dosed
them with alcohol and then again
everyone was tested on day seven and
what did they find firstly relative to
the group that got a full night of good
sleep every single night across the six
nights their memory was still there it
was present
but in the group that had alcohol dosed
on the first night there was a greater
than a 50 loss of their memory out on
day seven because of the impact of
alcohol on night one on REM sleep but
the frightening part was the Knight 3
group
so the third group they were very good
they said okay I've been let's say it's
a student you know I've been learning on
Wednesday and I've got all this
information I'm not going to go out with
my friends drinking on Wednesday night
because sleep is important for memory
and then I'm not gonna go out on
Thursday night because I've just learned
all this information but then on Friday
surely my memories are now safe I'm
gonna go out I'm gonna have a few drinks
oh Contra because even alcohol on night
3 caused almost the same it was about a
40 deficit in memory and what that tells
us is not just something about alcohol
it tells us that the sleeping brain is
still processing and consolidating and
digesting information three days after
the act of learning itself so yeah it
was a great study and you've got a
fantastic memory yeah that's the one
that blew me away and I was like oh my
God it's tough isn't it it's like please
come on I know why does biology have to
steal all the fun
but the but it raises all these
interesting questions that again for not
to belabor the point but having been
very involved through the size
foundation with funding various
scientific initiatives like science
costs money like and there is federal
funding you have NIH and so on but some
of these studies are probably unlikely
to be done anytime soon but I wonder
what the sort of fragile plasticity
range is for say associative slash
creative work versus straight
declarative memorize this list of 35
things right
and if those windows are different I
mean I would imagine they probably are
it's hard to say but it highlights for
me I mean yes we know a lot of things
but how many exciting questions there
are that we don't have
as of yet really clear answers to I
think that's a really interesting point
when it comes to therapy because therapy
is not just about you know targeting any
one individual memory it's trying to put
it together both in the context of your
back autobiography catalog of knowledge
and experience and it's also often in
therapy trying to
re-contextualize it with new information
to dissipate the negative effect that is
an incredibly complex thing for a memory
system to achieve in other words what
you're trying to do is break previous
associations form new associations and
change the essentially the emotional and
the informational waiting of memories
and the waiting of the different
connections
dissipate some increase others that's a
process that I suspect does not happen
across one night of sleep it happens
across multiple nights of sleep so have
your therapy on Monday and not on
Thursday if you're gonna drink on the
weekends exactly before you go I mean
I'm not kidding right it sounds like a
flippant comment but no I don't think it
is a flipping comment I think one may
want to think about engineering look
life is to be lived have a drink of
course I'm not being puritanical but if
you are let's say a student or you've
been you know learning new information
for a new job or you've been learning a
new skill for a new particular Sport and
you know when you've been learning and
you know when you probably want to have
a night out restructure those things to
implement them in the smartest way
possible for optimizing outcomes
yeah I will say fortunately for me in in
college I I have a just a kind of a
strange pseudo allergic reaction to most
beers so given that I was a dirt poor
along with most other students that was
the only thing really on offer so I
didn't drink very much I did pull a lot
of all-nighters
and what I would say and this is not to
encourage anyone to pull all-nighters
but if there's a 20 to 40 percent
penalty but you have not covered 80
percent of the material that might be on
a test you could still hypothetically
net out positive right yeah which is not
to say you should do it no that I think
that's very true but one of the other
interesting things that we did a study
and we never actually ended up
publishing the data we wanted to do some
follow-ups to these but it comes on to
this point I think you're right in that
logic that if you've not learned 80 to
90 percent even though your learning is
going to be 20 to 40 percent deficient
in its capacity time on task in that
break glass in case of emergency
situation is still going to be in your
favor you could argue yeah setting aside
of course all of the deleterious
consequences that come of that night of
sleep not to mention if you're driving
to your exam the next day your chances
of getting in a fatal car accident or
astronomically higher so bad but let's
just put that aside for now let's think
about it from an educational context
because I wrote an op-ed for when I was
back as faculty at Harvard and I was
asked to write a piece for the Harvard
Crimson we just published some work on
sleep and memory some of the first in in
that area and I wrote the op-ed and said
the frequency of pulling all-nighters at
the end of the semester for exams is so
Rife and it is not the student's fault
the fault is us the faculty why because
we end load the semester with all of
these inane idiotic exams and no wonder
what do you think is going to happen
you're putting students in a pressure
cooker of course they're all going to be
pulling all-nighters and it's
counterfactual to the very idea of
higher education so it's not the
student's fault we are the people at
fault and we need to reorganize and
restructure how we examine individuals
now of course that was the last time I
was ever asked to write an op-ed piece
for the Crimson I suppose that told me
everything I needed to know but it comes
on to my point which is this what's the
goal of Education the goal of Education
in my mind is twofold the first is to
brainwash you into thinking for yourself
the second is for you to gain long-term
information
so we did a study where we suggested
okay you haven't learned any of the
information and we tested your
hypothesis and sure enough yes time on
task returns some degree of a greater
benefit if you if you pull the
all-nighter and they were better in
terms of the testing relative to if you
chose you know obviously not to engage
in the material at all at that point
there's no learning whatsoever of course
you're worse what was interesting
however
is that in the people who have the same
amount of learning opportunity but then
got a full night of sleep afterwards
relative to the next day yes the people
who got sleep were better than those
people who were sleep deprived but then
we brought them back four weeks later
and then we tested them a second time
and the difference between those two
groups now was magnified almost tenfold
in other words the people who had been
sleep deprived the first night yes they
could still test to a degree they were
worse but they still got some degree of
the answers right but the amount of
catastrophic forgetting that happened
across those following four weeks
relative to the group that imprinted
those memories and saved them the first
night was far less there was a lot less
forgetting in the group that had it and
I put this in context simply because
I don't want to Simply educate human
Minds which is what I do as a job only
for you to test well the next day but
then two years later you've got none of
that information in your brain what's
the point of higher education there it
should be long term and so it's a very
insightful suggestion that you make and
we try to test it I should publish some
of that data question on that study were
the groups randomly assigned or were the
were the members of each cohort choosing
which cohort they wanted to belong to no
they were randomly assigned okay all
right now I was just wondering because I
was thinking if somebody chose to be in
the sleep deprivation group their
self-care might suck over over the
subsequent four weeks now I would say
though this the city is partly fluid in
terms of its selection bias because
ahead of time we tell them in the
consent form look you could be in a
group that is going to be sleep deprived
or a group that is going to you know
you're going to have your sleep sort of
well rested
and full and so would you like to
continue so in some ways they know that
they're rolling the dice they could or
could not be sleep deprived and so you
could argue there's still a selection
bias in that regard but it's not the we
don't do selection assignment we do
random assignment science is hard man
but a lot of folks don't realize just
how hard it is it is but it's so
rewarding though it is you know at the
moment when we analyze the data and I'm
sitting there with the student or I'm
analyzing data and we finally run the
statistics at that moment in time if I'm
lucky I know something that has never
been understood in the entirety of human
civilization and I cannot tell you how
much of a thrill and a privilege that is
and so is science hard it's brutally
hard but just that alone the hedonic
Rush that you get from De novo knowledge
gosh it's never left me and I don't
think it ever will yeah what a drug it's
quite the drug you know get a belt
around my arm the vein is up and I will
go intravenous with that all day long
so I want to ask you about sleep
spindles because you mentioned that in
the context of napping and how that
seems to be a determining Factor
or a critical factor in later
performance cognitive performance so I
want to come back to see if there are
any levers you can pull even if you
wouldn't recommend them for a long
period of time right like are there
lovers you could pull to increase the
frequency or amplitude of these sleep
spindles and I say that not really
knowing sleep signals well but but I'm
planting that seed so I'm going to let
that germinate but first I want to tell
you personal experience and see how you
might speak to it because
I have a pretty good out of the box
memory I think my my hardware and
genetics are reasonably good for it
but I've had a few outlier experiences
that are
still to this day
standout experiences and one of them was
while I was studying at a university in
China
and we're
we're responsible at the advanced levels
for
for being able to produce so not just
recognize but also
actively write many thousands of
characters and some of these characters
have you know 15 20 Strokes I mean
they're they're very intricate and I had
this experience of getting very sick I
can't remember exactly what caused it
maybe I never learned what caused it but
I had a fever
and there was this big exam the next day
and it was it was mostly characters but
in the context of essays so it was not
just memorizing characters and being
familiar with new terminology some of it
all very abstract so it's not like the
cat it's kind of like
hyperinflation that kind of stuff and I
was bedridden because I had a fever but
I knew this test was coming the next day
and I had a very high fever
and the way that my my studying
proceeded was I would wake up for 30
minutes and study super intensely and
then I would feel really sleepy and I
would just kind of fall asleep right on
the book on the bed and then I would
wake up and I would do another like 30
minute burst and then fall asleep and
when I went into the test the next day I
was feeling somewhat better but I'd
slept a lot of the previous day and I'd
studied a lot of the previous day and it
was intended to be I want to say maybe a
90 minute or two hour exam and I
finished the exam in something like 25
minutes and I handed it in and they were
like what are you doing and I was like I
think I'm done and they're like you're
can't be done and I was done Not only
was I done but I scored 95 plus percent
on the test and that blew me away and I
don't I don't really have a great way to
explain it and maybe it was just a freak
incident and I'm I'm reading too far
into it but I've spent a lot of time
around very very smart people including
people who have very impressive memories
and for me personally in my life I think
I've done a good job of learning many
different skills and memorizing many
different things but that particular
test stands out as very unusual
do you have any any thoughts yeah I do
and I think it comes back to the neural
mechanisms of memory consolidation so
there are at least two different
mechanisms non-mutually exclusive that
promote the cementing of that new
information but also the freeing up of
your short-term memory capacity and what
we've discovered we and others have have
done this work
the first method is a file transfer
mechanism that when you go into deep
non-rem sleep which by the way is dialed
up by way of infection when you get sick
you have an increase in sleep Drive
particularly for deep non-rem sleep we
know why there are a number of immune
factors inflammatory factors that call
up to play this thing called Deep Sleep
those immune factors are things like
cytokines and they are very sleep
inducing that's why you typically want
to curl up and get into bed that's why
you typically sleep more when you are
sick because the the human organism
understands that the very best health
insurance policy that it has the very
best Swiss army knife of health is this
tool called sleep and it brings all of
the Armament of sleep to the to the core
so part of the reason you were sleeping
so much is because you were undergoing
the infection you had a supercharged
amount of deep sleep it turns out what
happens to first mechanism of deep sleep
is that during and it's not just the
sleep spindles and it's not just the big
powerful slow waves of deep non-rem
sleep it's the combination of those two
that we've discovered so we've published
some work
as long as you get this perfect timing
between a slow wave and then a sleep
spindle it's almost like making sure
that the drummer is directly on the beat
in this rhythmic sort of capacity so you
have a slow wave and then you have a
sleep spindle riding on top of it this
electrical burst of activity the slow
waves they go up and down maybe once or
twice a second the sleep spindles they
burst at about 14 or 15 times per second
14 or 15 Hertz and it's the timing the
combined quality of these two deep sleep
brain waves that will shift memories
from a short-term vulnerable Reservoir
the hippocampus to a more permanent
long-term storage site within the brain
and protecting them and that long-term
storage site is the cortex that sits on
top of your brain and so it's
I I mean I don't want to do computer
brain analogies but I suppose the idea
would be a hippocampus is a little bit
like a USB stick that it's very good at
running around during the day and
grabbing individual files from different
locations but it has a limited storage
capacity but then at night you shift
those memories from that short-term
reservoir of the hippocampus to the hard
drive the cortex which gives you two
benefits the first is that that which
you learned before sleep is now shifted
over and protected and safe in the new
location but the second benefit is that
because you've cleared out the USB stick
of the hippocampus when you wake up
you've got a refreshed learning ability
and so you can start acquiring new files
all over again it's a symbiotic
relationship that we've discovered and I
think that's one of the explanations for
why you were able to just rip through
the material do it in a short burst by
the way we know that that's optimal for
learning it's called Mast versus spaced
practice if you try learn in one long
bout not great if you chunk it up into
different sort of segments your learning
is much better you still spend the same
two hours of learning but if you spread
it across four hours then two hours
straight much better but sleep is a part
of that so that's the the first of the
two mechanisms
that's fascinating I have a number of
follow-up questions the first is in
these short burst study sessions
how do you explain the benefit of that
versus longer duration I mean one thing
that leads to mind for me which may or
may not be true based on your read of
the literature but is that you have this
Primacy and recency effect in any given
study session so what that would mean is
the first thing you study and the last
thing you study you're generally going
to recall say in a word list better than
things in the middle okay
now if that's true in a four hour
session
you have let's just say this
this almost Golden Gate Bridge high
tension wire type of dip in the middle
but if you have shorter sessions the
actual drop of that high tension wire is
going to be less so your sort of average
retention over each individual session
will be higher and maybe that's just me
spouting nonsense but that's kind of
what jumps to mind does that mesh no it
does mesh very well which is that you're
getting the Primacy in the recency so
it's like this banana this bow shaped
where the informational in the middle of
the list you don't remember very well
but the stuff at the front and the the
back end of it you do remember well well
if you do only one learning session you
only get two stanchions either end of
the bridge of Primacy and recency but if
you split it up into six chunks then
you're getting six hits of Primacy and
recency which gives you a greater
benefit that's one of them the other we
think actually relates to attention
which is that your ability to focus and
attend and have a spotlight of
attentional focus you need attention to
imprint information at least consciously
there is non-conscious learning too but
and when you are constantly time on task
that Spotlight of attention starts to
fade and your ability to focus on what
you should learn decreases and therefore
what you learn decreases it's not really
related to the fact of your memory
fatiguing itself but I think there's
evidence for that too
what one of the things that I've always
been fascinated by and I want to do the
study but it's one of those you know
bucket list studies I don't think it's
quite as simple as that
I at least have found in my own personal
experience and heard from others that I
could be learning information you know
about organic chemistry for an hour and
I just know that I'm just starting to
fade my learning is just getting
miserable it's just diminishing returns
at this point but then if I close the
book and I start trying to learn French
I actually think my learning capacity is
renewed and refreshed and so I think
there is something about the context of
the information that the familiarity
versus the novelty can also
reinstantiate your learning ability does
that make some sense yeah yeah it
totally makes sense so I think this idea
of fatigue we don't really understand it
no yeah I mean there seem to be these
compartmentalized capabilities yeah it's
very it's not it's so wild yeah yeah I
will say for folks also we're you know I
use the example of word lists but having
attempted
somewhat successfully in most cases to
acquire different
skills motor skills
of sports
Etc different capabilities could even be
something like poker which is kind of a
combination of all sorts of things that
the same type of
of short duration sessions and breaks
helps it's not limited to Pure what we
might consider book learning at least in
my experience let me ask two questions
and I'll let you pick the first one I'd
love to hear you comment on both though
so the first is if you wanted to put
your sleep spindles on hyperdrive
for a short period of time
fahuna's final exam right I don't I
expect these slow wheels of
institutionalized Academia
will probably not completely reformat
the end of semester testing
default that they have had for so long
so
if someone were had sort of infinite
resources
and they wanted to put their sleep
spindles on hyperdrive how might they do
that the other one is you mentioned a
term earlier with respect to lucid
dreaming that was charlatan science so
it was considered Charlotte in science
for a long time until it wasn't and I
would be super curious to know if
there's anything that is currently and
this might make you uncomfortable but
I'll do it
if there's anything that is currently
considered
along the lines of Charlotte and science
that you think might similarly bear out
as lucid dreaming good
great two questions so in terms of the
sleep spindles and I wouldn't probably
just focus on the sleep spindles I would
focus on the
the combination of deep slow brain waves
yeah the synchronization of this what we
call is Phase amplitude coupling is the
technical term which is yeah the phase
of the wave and the coupling of that
yeah it's like two people jumping on a
trampoline at the same time exactly yeah
and you sort of want those to sort of
just go just in this lovely rhythmic
sink
we've we've been developing some brain
stimulation technology to see if we can
do this we can certainly boost your deep
sleep brain waves with brain stimulation
we can also improve your sleep spindles
and here what we're doing is we're
applying electricity through the brain
where you don't feel it it's so small
it's a small voltage but we can
stimulate at a slow frequency brainwave
and we can act like a acquire to that
flagging lead vocalist and boost those
slow waves but we can also stimulate at
the frequency of the sleep spindles
which is a much faster frequency
somewhere between sort of 12 to 15 Hertz
12 to 15 cycles per second and we can
also induce those sleep spindles by the
way motor learning is another good
example we did some studies gosh 10
years ago now at least where we found
that motor skill learning was also
dependent on a lighter stages of non-rem
sleep but once again on sleep spindles
and a recent group this wasn't us
although we're doing these to these two
they applied stimulation at the Sleep
spindle frequency range and they were
able to improve aspects of motor skill
learning as well which is kind of wild
when you think about airline pilots
musicians and professional athletes you
know can you actually
adopt and learn some of these new skills
and then supercharge them overnight with
electrical brain stimulation is that
going to be in 10 years time a banned
electrosutical rather than a band
pharmaceutical yeah or it will be a
required electrocutable for say airline
pilots correct ethical questions does
that raise right exactly you know and
what are we trying to do and you know
always got to think about free lunches
and if you ever get one so so I would
say that that's probably one of the
areas I would also say that the sleeping
brain often takes care of itself what
we've learned is that when you have
people do intensive learning sessions
and you measure their sleep that
following night relative to when they've
not been doing intensive learning
sessions lo and behold the brain after
the Intensive learning session
artificially for that night it's not
artificially adaptively for that night
increases the amount of spindles that it
gets so your brain actually knows what
it needs and itself medicates with
greater numbers of spindles so we may
almost not need to worry about it it's
wild isn't it an amazing piece of wet
where we carry between our ears what a
thing the other aspect of memory that
you could optimize and people have been
doing this
and I don't think it's mainstream yet
comes back to the second mechanism of
why sleep is good for memory it's not
just about shifting memories from short
term to long term it's about memory
replay and this story emerged back in
the 1990s when a scientist called Bruce
McNaughton of the University of Arizona
he was measuring the memory cell
activity in rats as they were running
around a maze and he was trying to learn
how the hippocampus codes amaze and
basically how it builds a memory Circuit
of the Maze and he was recording
individual cells in the hippocampus and
he wasn't doing this but you can just
think of this as each cell has a tone to
it and as the rat would run around the
maze what he would hear is the signature
of learning that would sound a little
bit like
as the rat was running around the maze
he was listening to the brain imprinting
these memories the brilliant part of his
study was that he didn't stop recording
When the session ended he kept recording
from that Memory Center as those rats
went into sleep and went into deep
non-rem sleep and when they went into
deep non-rem sleep
he kept listening and when you eavesdrop
on the sleeping brain Not only was the
memory replayed but it wasn't replayed
at waking speed it was replayed almost
10 times faster so instead what he was
hearing instead of it was he was hearing
as if these rats were just replaying the
memory at high frequency speed as if
they're etching the memory into the
glass surface of the brain and scoring
the memory Trace even more powerfully
so we know that memory replay is a
critical component of that
then studies
it probably restarted back with some
French scientists in the early 2000s and
then there was a big paper in nature by
a German group and they tried to hijack
the system of memory replay and it was
brilliant it was so clever and now Ken
parlor at Northwestern has been doing
some of these studies
here's what they did they had people
learn information but they Associated
that information with somatosensory
stimuli and what I mean by that is
you're learning a list of words and then
during that list of words I'm infusing a
rose perfume up your nose with a mask
and what you're doing the brain is
bonding the the scent the odor of the
rose with the learned information so now
you've got a bonded memory with the odor
then what they would do is they would
let those individuals fall asleep
and during deep non-rem sleep when we
believe the memories are being replayed
they started to reperfuse that Rose odor
up their nose and as a consequence the
next day there was about a 40 to 50 50
Improvement in their memory because they
had brute forced the reactivation of the
memory it's almost as though they
decided to take that memory and give it
VIP access to the memory replay during
non-rem sleep and you start to cherry
pick information and then can parlor and
others they started to look at this and
they did it even more cleverly I think
the way the game over here in America is
actually called memory where it's a set
of cards all out on the table and each
card has its own purr so you turn one
card over and it's a house and you turn
another card over and somewhere in the
rest of the deck there is another house
that's the match and then there is one
tea kettle and then there is one fire
engine and so they would do all of these
things but they did this on on the
computer and each time they were
learning this sort of associative
spatial layout of information when they
would turn over the tea kettle they
would hear a tea kettle sound and when
they turn over the fire engine they
would hear a fire engine sound so once
again they were bonding a sound a
congruent semantic sound with that
particular information visually
and then they let them sleep and as they
went into deep non-rem sleep they would
replay those sounds at what we call a
sub-awakening threshold where it was
loud enough to get into the brain
critical detail yeah please please
please don't do that so what they were
able to do is essentially an even more
selective process of cherry picking so
now whatever I want to serve up to the
menu of this thing called sleep at night
in terms of the different dishes of
memory I get to choose I can say no no I
don't want that information I want this
particular information tonight and I'm
going to develop this auditory playlist
and so the question then becomes can you
start using that method is the cheap
version of that that I'm going to study
organic chemistry and I'm going to blaze
up some green tea incense which I
personally really like and then before I
go to bed at night am I going to put
back on the Green
T incense and start trying to stuff that
back up my nose and either improve my
memory or burn my house down and be a
scientist no more and char grill the
rest of my body because it's a desperate
fire safety hazard and you'd never want
to do it but this is the idea there's
something that we're starting to
understand about the sleeping brain that
not just is understanding but it gives
us the ability to take control and at
that point that becomes kind of scary
because yeah you know should we be
taking control of a process that maybe
is not really our purview to be in
control of
sounds like the story of humankind in a
nutshell right there yeah I know you can
almost see visions of the atomic bomb by
the way I would say that
it's a bit extreme I think but what
happens during REM sleep is really quite
different it's during deep non-rem sleep
that those memories are replayed at as I
said about 10 times faster but when you
go into dream sleep this is work done by
Matt Wilson at MIT he found that the rap
brain does replay memories during REM
sleep but it doesn't replay them faster
and it doesn't even replay them at
waking speed
it replays them at about 0.5 times the
speed
so it's like listening to this podcast
and all of a sudden you hit that sort of
button that says no go slow and everyone
sort of slows down
and I think this has relationships to
you know the component of time and our
time perception
which is which is totally freaky by the
way
time and I I kind of I've written about
this and have a few theories and we
we're really interested
about how to do this by the way I
haven't forgotten about your your
question as to what is short and Science
and I will come back to that because
I've vaguely still holding on to my
memory despite being in the foothills of
middle age the time perception is
interesting when you and I let's say you
know we've gone a long whole flight and
you're lucky enough to actually fall
asleep on the flight and it's dark and
on the flight when you wake up what is
one of the first things that you do
one of the first things that you do is
you check your watch you check your
phone because you're trying to look to
the time because when you sleep you lose
all conscious perception of time you've
got no idea and that's the reason that
you check how long have I been asleep
why don't you know I don't know because
I don't track time when I'm sleeping
however when you dream something
different happens and I think you've
maybe you've had this experience I
certainly have and many people have your
alarm goes off and you have a snooze
button and the snooze button is for five
minutes so the alarm wakes you up you
hit the snooze button and you are
dreaming and you go back to sleep and
you go back to Dreaming maybe it's the
same dream maybe it's a different dream
and then the alarm goes off again and
it's been five minutes in the waking
world but you personally you think that
wasn't five minutes I felt like I was
dreaming for 20 minutes 30 minutes 40
minutes as if time is different in the
Dreamscape and what I've described this
as is time dilation yeah that it's
during dream sleep that we almost
stretch time out
what would be the neurobiological basis
of that well I think it could be some of
this rat work that suggests that perhaps
during dream sleep the brain slows down
the recapitulation of time
and you can have all sorts of fun with
this idea I you know Christopher Nolan
was wise enough to consult some sleep
researchers and you know come up with
this idea in Inception way we'd have
different dream levels where in the
first level you know five minutes in the
waking world is now you know 50 minutes
at the first level of the dream and you
go down the next level and now five
minutes is now five hours and then the
next level it's five years and the next
level it's 50 years and you're
constantly doing this sort of time
dilation as it were it comes up with
some fascinating ideas but science just
getting to that position now where we
can understand time during sleep because
it is strange it's a very strange thing
time with sleep if you sit with that for
a minute I mean that is one of the
strangest
experiences that is very hard to fit in
to our sort of paradigms of of thinking
about things right now right I mean the
idea that you could have more than five
minutes you can have 40 minutes of
experience subjective experience in five
minutes of waking Earth time if we take
the Fidelity of the first-hand
experience to be high in so much as it
being a real experience that is
it raises a lot of very very hard to
answer questions well I think it's
fascinating too and I have a right now I
do have a neural hypothesis for this and
there's a part of the brain called the
insular cortex that sort of is in the
left and the right side but it's buried
deep inside and it serves many different
functions but one of its functions is
the mapping of your bodily state of your
emotions and the updating it from one
moment to the next to the next so the
insular cortex is consistently mapping
the physiological state of your body
from one moment to the next to the next
the reason I bring that up is because
the physiological emotional state of
your body contributes to time how does
it do that I think you and I and
everyone listening has also had that
experience where they said I just had
this emotional experience and all of a
sudden time slowed down I remember when
I was Avid cyclist and I've been knocked
off my bike a few times and I remember
one time I was going
going through and a car came out of a
junction and I could just see it and it
hit me I went through the windscreen of
the car and came out
and that moment of time which was
obviously pretty pretty traumatic kind
of pretty emotional event when you get
knocked off your bike through a car
windscreen I time just slowed down
the emotion was so intense that all of a
sudden it was like
you know when you see on a video camera
you go from a standard frame rate and
all of a sudden and you can now do it on
your iPhone you can slow it down and you
can get really high resolution slow
tempo slow motion activity it was like
that because my the insular cortex was
starting to map with you know much
higher frame rates and therefore time
slowed down and I could I realized I was
going to be hit and I realized I'm
clipped into my pedals on the bike I'm
gonna clip out because I don't want to
go under the car where my bike is going
I'd much prefer to go over the car onto
the windscreen and off so I remember and
that happened obviously within
milliseconds but I remember clipping out
thinking all of this WOW within time and
I think what's happening is that the
insular cortex has some interesting
changes we see it changing in its
activity during dream sleep my
prediction is that if I start to map
your perception of time in dream sleep I
think it's going to be predicted by
changes in activity within this part of
the brain called the insular cortex
which is constantly mapping the
affective visceral state of your
experience consciously so I've got a
neural Theory it's hand waving but yeah
the time machine if I try to then just
restate that so I ensure that I'm
understanding it correctly
is it that you're
insular cortex yeah insula insular yeah
insular cortex has the ability to
effectively increase your frame rate in
certain circumstances which is
ostensibly resource intensive and
there's a cognitive load therefore it
doesn't do it all the time right because
I mean reality perception of reality in
a sense is a shorthand
a lot of the times of sorts I mean it
seems that way at least otherwise we
would just be you know on psychedelics
all the time experientially and that
would be it's just
unmanageable is that a fair lay
restatement of what you just said it's a
accurate statement in the sense that the
insula cortex does do that mapping of
time but it does seem to do it all of
the time and some of it probably
non-consciously but they have densities
were let's say that you ask people
to
say count time count two minutes of time
and they'll just sit there and they'll
just try and sense time quantify time
and the accuracy from one individual to
the next in terms of mapping that
subjective sense of two minutes is
predicted by the insular activity itself
the greater the insular activity the
greater your Precision of mapped timing
so it really does seem to be one of the
seats of timed of mapped time I should
say it makes me wonder if this is one of
the unmeasured
performance enhancing variables in for
instance batters in Major League
Baseball who claim to be able to see the
stitching on the baseball as it travels
towards them right as a fastball right
and how much of that is innate versus
train right if it's innate it may be
very interesting if that were a sort of
deciding factor in performance yeah
certain Sports
let's hop to the charlatan science and
the question is not so much what is
charlatan science because I think that's
somewhat evident in the term itself I
think most people kind of grok what that
means the question is like what what is
currently being
dismissed or
cast aside much as lucid dreaming was
for a long time that may in fact become
a
credible area of inquiry
in the foreseeable future is there and
we can always edit this out but I'm just
very curious to me
and this is probably just because we've
been talking about dreaming for so long
I do have a theory of dreaming that
is currently not very well supported
most science right now suggests just as
I did when it comes to dreaming that we
are amnesic that we forget most if not
all of our dreaming life that it's just
not imprinted into our brains
I think that there could be a day and a
time in the future where we realize we
have been desperately wrong about this
and that our dreaming lives are
influencing our waking lives in a far
more powerful way than we ever thought I
was going to say dreamed than we ever
thought possible and here's the reason
we know that there is such a thing as
non-conscious memory or implicit memory
and I think people have conflated an
issue with memory that is about
accessibility versus availability
and what I mean by that is you can learn
some information and it can be available
it can be there in your brain that
memory is present
but you for whatever reason lose the IP
address to the memory so it is not
accessible
and right now we have conflated
accessibility of dreams with
availability of Dreams such that we say
well you can't remember most of your
dreams so we assume that that memory is
not available that that memory is not
present in your brain I don't believe
that's true I think that memory could be
present available but it's simply not
accessible and the evidence I have for
this and it's happened you know to me
multiple times
I can be
I'll wake up in the morning and I know
for a fact I was dreaming and the harder
I try I just can't remember it and it
just seems to evaporate as if the memory
is gone
and the availability of the memory its
presence in my brain we all assume in
science is no longer there that memory
has evaporated
but then two or three days later I could
be in the shower and I'm washing my hair
and I look at the shampoo bottle and
there's something about the label that
triggers the instant recollection of
that dream from three days ago and it
all comes flooding back in other words
it wasn't a problem of availability of
the dream it was a problem of
accessibility of the dream memory the
memory is there
it's just that I don't have conscious
access to it now if that is true and if
I can prove that and I've got some ideas
I mean I've always got way too many
experiments than I can do but if I can
prove that that's true what that could
unleash is the maybe scary fact that
most of our dreams firstly are residing
within us
and vast amounts of our dreaming life
are non-consciously implicitly unaware
to us influencing our everyday choices
and our behaviors that right now sounds
a lot like Charlotte and science that
sounds like Hui to me the you know that
sounds like total BS and you know strong
words strong words Matt Walker Matt
Walker used to do some like you know
fairly hard-nosed good Neuroscience data
and then towards the end of his career
he kind of lost it he was going on
podcasts and they started dreaming of
all these crazy theories and that was
the end of him next we know he's selling
books door-to-door in some odd country
but I think that that's to me that could
be a wild and plausible currently
Charlotte and nonsensical idea but if we
can prove it and I think it's a testable
hypothesis that's why I entertain it
because I'm a scientist and it has to be
a testable hypothesis what does that
mean for us as a species in terms of
what dreams
do and influence to us as a species and
as a society yeah you know if you can't
get the funding for the study you might
be able to sell it to Hollywood I'm just
imagining
a film premise where you have
something like waking mat and dreaming
Matt and those are certainly one in the
same in some respects but perhaps in the
same way that you can consciously
attempt to recall
experiences data things you've memorized
from your Waking Life perhaps through
Lucidity you can query your dream memory
and be more active as a participant in
that mindscape in sculpting that
experience I mean how amazing would it
be if and I'm getting way out there now
but you know I've had too much coffee as
I said earlier so if in the same way
that you could try to recall
perhaps with the help of someone like a
family member what your
fifth birthday was like or what happened
when you graduated from elementary
school and perhaps you could you could
have a similar attempt perhaps
successful at sort of aided inquiry to
identify what your dreams were like when
you were three four five eight eleven
right it opens up all sorts of narrative
possibilities if not scientific let's
write the screenplay I'm represented by
WME I don't know if you're with the same
agency but we should definitely like
let's do the joint screenplay and let's
sell it for probably about twenty
dollars
yeah it's like here's a great idea it'll
cost just a mere 20
to 100 million dollars to try to do a
test reel good luck I'll email
Christopher Nolan see
well yeah if you can email Christopher
Nolan I'd love to have him on the
podcast too
but that's a whole separate conversation
so if if we're looking at a few
different things here I mean we've
covered a lot of ground
I would like to chat for a second about
my
fever-induced hypernesia my experience
with that Chinese test and I was
listening to you describe the cytokines
and inflammatory markers and so on which
would be associated with that fever and
it raised the question for me of how you
might simulate that without going out
and eating rotten beef or whatever gave
me food poisoning because I wouldn't
recommend that and then I started to
think about
exercise
and it's a relationship to or how it
might affect
sleep and memory and certainly you have
a whole Cascade of things that can
happen with different types of exercise
including
brain Drive neurotrophic factor into all
these various things but I was wondering
you know if you if you go through
intense exercise let's just say intense
resistance exercise you are going to
trigger I would think many of the same
type of inflammatory responses and
compensatory mechanisms that you might
when you're experiencing an infection in
a sense and they're not identical I'm
not saying that but where I'm going is
I'm wondering if there's a role for
intense exercise that is
pro-inflammatory in the short term for
enhancing memory
I think there is and it's funny you
should mention that literally this week
on on my podcast I released the first of
a three-part series all about sleep and
exercise and it's exactly what you
predict
that exercise hugely beneficial for
Sleep the principal stage of sleep that
it seems to induce is an increase in the
amount of deep non-rem sleep and
particularly the power of those powerful
big slow brain waves
one of the interesting things is though
that there is no free lunch that you
when you exercise intensively if you
look across the cities yes you increase
the amount of deep sleep but it does
seem to come at the cost of REM sleep
that you will have a reliable and
cystical drop in the amount of REM sleep
now I don't think that's anything to be
concerned about if you're exercising I
think it's simply that once again Mother
Nature knows what the menu of sleep
stage options should be and prescribes
the right one for whatever conditions
you've been doing that day whether it's
physical exercise whether it's learning
intensively material that is figured out
for you but you're absolutely right
exercise will induce that part of that
is because of the low-grade
inflammation that it's a
pro-inflammatory state by way of
exercise I think there are other factors
too that probably help with that some of
them may be related to temperature some
of them may be related to the degree of
parasympathetic downshoot that you get
after exercise so you get very
sympathetic and stress in terms of the
nervous system of course but then you
typically have this drop that comes down
and you dip below your typical level
that's what you see in heart rate you
see it in blood pressure that's one of
the benefits of exercise so I think this
nice down shoot shifting from the fight
or flight down to the parasympathetic in
part is one of the reasons why you get
better sleep by way of exercise
it benefits across all ages by the way
it's not just that young people benefit
from exercise old people do as well you
can look at different forms of exercise
and right now I don't think there's
enough data there's some data that you
know aerobic versus resistance training
may lead to somewhat greater benefits on
on sleep at least on deep non-rem sleep
and the consistency of your sleep you're
saying on the aerobic side yeah so
aerobic seems to potentially outdo if
you put them head to head in a sort of
Coke Pepsi challenge it seems to be that
aerobic wins out somewhat basically
doing cardio seems to produce a greater
benefit relative to resistance training
in other words lifting weights but
lifting weights is still better than
doing nothing at all so don't feel
worried about the fact that oh my
goodness I I'm principally someone who
just goes into the gym and lifts weights
I'm not going to get a sleep benefit you
will relative to being sedentary that's
definitely the worst situation but
aerobic seems to of course it's not we
call it aerobic exercise but most of the
time it's anaerobic it's where you go
without oxygen that's where all of the
good stuff can happen too although I'm a
big fan of Zone 2 as well Peter Patia
thank you well hold on a second so if
we're talking about anaerobic does that
mean that you're talking about cardio in
quotation marks that is above your
lactic threshold or otherwise sort of
pushing the boundaries of your aerobic
capacity as as opposed to
lower intensity steady state aerobics
because I it's it's the devil's in the
details with this stuff right yeah and
that's true for resistance training
because there's such a spectrum of
different types of resistance training
and I I'll just say as a quick side note
for folks do both like absolutely you
really don't want to have sarcopenia and
lose muscle mass year on year as you get
older that is a it's just a recipe for
disaster so do your weight training or
resistance training but when you say
anaerobic in this case what type of
protocol are we talking about yeah so
people have looked at sort of hits of us
hit routines hii high intensity High
intervalter interval training and
they've also looked at steady state
cardio right now I don't think we have
enough data to separate between those
two simply that both of those will
provide a nice sleep benefit and a boost
both in the it's not just that it boosts
the amount of deep sleep it also boosts
the continuity of your sleep meaning
that you're going to wake up fewer times
throughout the night and you'll have a
nice longer Consolidated bout of Total
Sleep as a consequence that's one of the
other benefits of exercise size on sleep
but again resistance training also
provides those benefits too they're just
not quite as voluminous
but into your question no one has done
the systematic study where you try to I
mean I it's only now being worked out in
the field of exercise itself which is
really understanding when you put all of
these different flavors of hit versus
zone two exactly what are the nuanced
you know neurobiological and biophysical
changes within the body and the Brain
regarding sleep we've got no idea there
are cities that have done these
different flavors but they've never done
a randomized control trial where you
assign people to each one of these two
in the same protocol and then ask you
know basically Coke Pepsi Dr Pepper
Sprite whatever you want to line up
challenge and put them all head to head
to see which one was out we don't know
right now it's really hard
from what I can tell to
Implement studies and exercise science
in a really clean precise way and I
don't want to name names but I I've at
many points volunteered to be a subject
and experiments all over the place and
in some very fancy places and I remember
being in one study and there was the it
entailed circuit training and so you'd
go to different stations and you had to
do bench press pull up Etc and
there were a number of other subjects
in this room and were rotating around
these stations and I would see one
person doing bench press very controlled
in a slower Cadence you know like four
seconds down two seconds up and then the
next two people would be bouncing the
bar off their chest using momentum and I
just thought to myself like the time
under tension and the loading here is
apples and oranges like you're not
actually getting a clean signal because
it's it's not standardized well enough
so that's that's certainly a challenge I
think with a lot of these studies let me
ask you I'm gonna I'm gonna do a hard
left turn just because
you've you've inspired me and I actually
want to try to get to the gym now
but let's talk about urination so yeah I
love
drinking beverages I'm very well
hydrated and there's a lot of upside to
that but one of the downsides is I
almost always get up and pee in the
middle of the night that is not a new
thing I mean I'm sure that the plumbing
starts to
Wane in its strength over time
unfortunately but but this has been
pretty consistent for me I drink a lot
of liquids so the the question is and
I'll say a few more things but the
question is
what are some approaches for minimizing
this as an issue as a problem because it
does interrupt that continuity of sleep
and I see a market difference in my
feelings of restfulness on subsequent
mornings when I do or do not get up to
go to the bathroom yeah so what one is
drink less okay fine I seem to be very
bad at following that advice another is
hey take something like a desmopressin
which is an antidiuretic hormone that
which no one should do without medical
supervision I tested that the problem is
on I ended up experiencing orthostatic
hypotension whereas
dizzy dizzy and then yeah potentially
pass out yeah I'd get really dizzy and I
thought wow that's dangerous I don't
want to screw around with it are there
any other techniques or thoughts that
you have on this particular issue
because I know a lot of men in
particular seem to contend with it as
they get older yeah I've definitely
experienced this as I'm getting older I
used to sleep throughout the night now I
probably get up you know on average at
least once every every second night to
go to the restroom we don't have a
particularly good approach to this in
terms of medications there's nothing
that
there are a few medications out there to
try to decrease the the likelihood and
the frequency of those and I think those
medications are more about trying to
increase the expulsion of your InTouch
that before bed you expel more of that
fluid and so less is left as you are
casting off into sleep to trigger The
Awakening but there's nothing that I
know that helps suppress that reflex and
that desire during sleep
and it's really then at that point
unfortunately down to how do I taper off
my fluid intake throughout the late
afternoon in the early evening and is it
worth it to me to get that continuity of
sleep is it that
I don't stop drinking the number of
drinks that I have but starting at 5 p.m
or 4 P.M I actually will just have half
the size of the drink that I normally
would so I don't fool my brain into
thinking you are in a famine of you know
fluid I still have the same number of
drinks so my habit is still satisfied
with having three or four you know
whatever drinks I'm having but the
volume is halved and therefore the
psychology is still easier to adopt but
the impact is reduced by 50 that's one
of the ways that you could try to sort
of or at least I've tried to get around
the effect and when people speak to me I
advise them that that's what one method
that you can try to fool your brain
don't feel as though you're
you're stopping yourself from doing what
you normally like to do but you still
get half of the fluid intake other than
that it's very challenging
yeah all right well I'll try the Dr
Walker half glass trick
tonight and see how see how that goes
I'll report back
this has been so much fun we've covered
a lot of ground is there anything that
you would like to mention anything you'd
like to point people to because it's
certainly I think we could refresh where
people can find you online just so they
can track you down and see what you're
up to so please feel free to add your
your closing comments yep people can
find me I'm on Twitter at sleep Diplomat
I'm on Instagram
at Dr Matt Walker that's
d-r-m-a-t-t-w-a-l-k-e-r and I also have
a podcast if you're not sick and tired
of my voice and it's creatively called
the Matt Walker podcast which can be
found on all platforms and that's
probably about it
all right well thank you for taking the
time and always enjoy our conversations
another time thank you for the privilege
of being a a repeat offender a second
repeat offender on the podcast for all
of the sins that I've offered in terms
of sleep advice so thank you I'm all
about repeat offenders and of course
thank you for putting on the gloves
to everybody listening we will have
links to everything that we discussed in
the show notes as per usual at tim.blog
podcast and until next time
try those half glasses of water out and
see how that works add a little bit of
sex in between as well and maybe a
little bit of sex yeah yeah a little bit
of sex sprinkled here and there and if
you don't have a fantastic partner then
maybe your right or left hand will do
the trick yeah for that 47
all glossful and left hand keep your
right hand free and you're good to go
for Sleep be safe out there folks and as
I mentioned until next time thanks for
tuning in